Oh three two one Tim Poole you mad man
how's it going dude the ride that you
made to get here
you drove from the other side of the
continent in a blackout van well I mean
you've had guests on who've driven here
yeah I mean I drove here you drove here
but it took four days it took four days
it's a different kind of drive have you
ever done that before
oh yeah yeah yeah not in the van but
I've driven around the country too many
times the Vans pretty dope yeah I told
you last year
yes I was getting the van and I got a
bunch of people on Twitter making fun of
me like who's gonna get a bug up van
he's crazy
I got a van you got a bug out van was
living that thing Oh totally dude this
the solar power on it yeah
last you forever that's pretty amazing I
didn't know that you could power
everything so you have a solar power
roof panels that is is it less effective
in like Jersey where it's cloudy right
now you know Tom yeah how much
difference is it ones cloudy I mean
several orders of magnitude yeah yeah it
like barely work I mean it works it
works it works well enough but right
here works great right here the Sun is
so intense and just gnarly you go
outside you can feel on your skin hmm
yeah my solar things like your good
forever
don't worry like turn the a/c on full
blast really if so if I run the a/c on
full blast it will probably last if I
start when the Sun comes up and it may
be like I don't know 14 hours wow that's
that's that that's intense though man
AC if I use just the fan ticket
circulation I can play playstation I can
watch movies I can turn the music on
full blast and you can probably with AC
you can probably turn it on and off as
the temperature goes up and down yeah
and the fan is is it insulated at all oh
man like crazy yeah yeah yeah these guys
I was trying to find somebody to help me
modify this thing for a while I think
when I was here last time I had the van
but was empty and then I found these
guys in in Jersey they do like they do
police modification stuff like gun racks
and you know like seats and I guess
because the van life thing started
getting big they III did a Google search
I couldn't find anyone man life thing
yeah van life man
what are you talking about so on YouTube
van life was this big trend I think it's
kind of waning a little bit but there
was one woman who got like two million
subscribers and one video because she
in her van with her pet snake or
something like that oh she's probably
hot is she hot she's younger I think so
I haven't actually seen the video so I'm
like making the assumption that you know
that makes us make a YouTube video
you're a single female in a van you know
and I think the video was like here's
how I shower so naturally oh you go good
move yeah but there's a four million
views yeah yeah these guys over where I
live I guess I couldn't find anybody to
do this the wait lists are crazy like
they're pro companies that do van
modification eight-month wait period
really yeah so I went on google maps of
all places just because I was like maybe
maybe that's my problem I typed in van
modification and two miles from me boom
this guy pops up and he does him and his
company they did modifications for local
police departments unlike SWAT van
surveillance vans and things like that I
wonder if I'm supposed to be saying that
probably not finally not but I tell you
to keep your mouth shut
no actually he was like yeah I'll let
people know we do this work you know
what's the name of the company
diversified vehicle systems I think man
if I got that name where I'm gonna feel
so bad
well CPU fine Jim yeah diversified
vehicle system sound or or services yeah
and its he's got cool photos of like
SWAT vans and stuff I'm stuck too dude
you know he ought to be out that thing's
amazing it is interesting that you can
power everything from the solar panels
you can power your monitors because you
have it set up in there
we have monitors and lights you have
cameras what kind of did you have an
internet connection
I use my phones but but there is there
is on the roof this thing called a wine
guard and have 5g on your phone right
yep oh yes sir here it is diversified
vehicle services that's him that's quick
that's master interior before the van
hesita okay yeah you're making this
guy's week good cool good for him he's
cool dude yeah so how long did it take
for them to trick it out I think it took
like a maybe three weeks to a month and
then melt super confident to drive that
thing all the way across the country
totally was he weird at all uh no I was
pretty awesome
was there any spots you stopped in
you're like what in the [ __ ] like hour
Barstow Stipe type areas there was just
because like the pandemic and all well
the pandemic and they're weird already
I've driven across this country too much
and I've purposefully in the past have
driven through really weird parts like
off of interstate highways I've been at
some pretty crazy place
I've been in one motel that once looked
like used to be a prison or something
you used to be a prison they turned out
no I'm just saying it looked like like
there's no windows there's just like
those block windows you can't see
through with like the weird wavy glass I
had no idea what the building used to be
but it was a motel now it looked like I
was in a meat locker or something but
there was there's one town I think it
was in New Mexico I don't want to say
the name cuz I get it wrong but they put
up a sign saying no one's allowed in no
but a whole town the whole town was
because of those and damn it yep
no one's allowed can you do that it said
no visitors no business something like
that it said it's like residents only
it's not legal I don't think it is
that's weird right a lot of this stuff
is like what what is legal as far as
like as far as lockdowns what's legal is
it completely up to the their this is a
debate right now right whether or not
it's completely up to the governors
whether it's the mayors have individual
liberty in whatever town and I mean I'll
tell you what sounds like the
Constitution doesn't exist right now
well I wouldn't go that far
there's definitely some protections
let's put it this way let's be as
generous as possible protections that
are in place to shield the vulnerable
people from the pandemic but a lot of
folks feel like there's some
overstepping and there's a problem with
Powerman if you give power to people
they do not like to give it back they
always think it's better with me in
charge yeah that's what there was one
documentary I saw a long time ago some
activists went to like the the CEO of
shell and he talked to him and he was
like listen you got to understand I'm
trying my hardest with me at the helm
I'm doing such good things for the
environment they always think they're
the benevolent dictator that's why I
think decentralization is so much more
important in in so many different
aspects like yeah that is a weird trait
that human beings have when they get
into a position like that right but the
type of person who would want to be a
governor to begin with the type of
person that would want to run the entire
state yeah I don't I don't I don't trust
any individual to have good intentions
well I should say they do have good
intentions but I don't trust them to
actually know what's best for everybody
there's no way you can I mean just to be
able to be accurate about all the
different predictions in this
this regard you know when you're talking
about this pandemic thing I've one of
the biggest problems I'm looking at is
who determines what's essential and
what's not essential
yeah weed stores are essential so we
heard it like in Michigan for instance
they were closing off certain parts of
certain stores did you hear about this
No
so a lot of people took it because there
were photos of seeds at Walmart or
something where there's like tape saying
you can't you know this part of the
store is closed and so the story went
out that you weren't allowed to buy
seeds anymore no story actually was that
stores over 50,000 feet had to close off
non-essential areas like flooring and
gardening and things like that and who's
to determine what is and isn't essential
about any of those services particularly
gardening I mean if there's a time where
you want to have your own food readily
available in your back yard and at the
time well even think about just general
hardware if they're gonna shut that down
what if you what if hole breaks up in
your floor you know your kid falls
through or something yeah that fixed
yeah I mean that's that's a serious
safety issue so you've got these
governors determining what is essential
and what isn't I heard a good argument
for keeping liquor stores open because I
was like come on liquor stores but
someone said actually it is to prevent
people from going into detox from having
problems detoxing where they would take
up a hospital bed that we need
potentially need because of the virus I
that make sense I also think about the
reality of you take away booze in a time
of a crisis yeah and you're gonna see
people's nerves snap real quick have you
seen the video of this guy jogging down
the street he examines everybody's
recyclables it's all filled with vodka
bottles and tequila and whiskey and wine
and so it goes from house to house he's
like let's see what they've been up to
oh well people are so stressed out
they're just getting hammered yeah
that's me liver damage when this is all
a lot of horses - yeah I heard that's
that's going up Oh your people and
domestic abuse and /or and suicide
here's here's the prediction I made you
know very early on I was talking to my
friends actually I think I said this
what they're gonna do they're gonna say
we're only gonna keep things closed
until April 12th and that's what Trump
said at first Easter we're gonna come
open up and I said about a week before
they're gonna say no we gotta push it
back sure enough April 30th then May
15th now it's June 1st they're even
first for who we just I think New York
just announced
they said June first yeah but I think
they said they're gonna start May 15th
with outside of New York City right
there's not that Cuomo said I'm not
entirely sure but feel like you said
there I do know a lot of jurisdictions
have slowly entered you know the phase
one there was that Trump argument with
with camp and in Georgia about going too
fast and stuff like that yeah so I guess
you know people starting to realize if
you don't open things up there's nothing
to save right right what's what's
freaking to me about all of this is the
tribalism behind whether or not we
should reopen the economy or stay locked
down it's connected to everything right
what do you mean the tribalism it's can
I totally yeah it's it's it's so you
know I had a friend messaging me saying
we're stupid people who want haircuts
are gonna get us all killed and they're
going on protesting and and the first
thing I'm like you really don't think
just because one guy was holding that
dumb science what everyone is thinking
right now that's not the case but what's
crazy to me is you had the UN a UN
adviser come out and say we're looking
at a hundred and thirty million people
are going to starve because of the
economic shutdown and that's gonna be
much worse potentially than the actual
pandemic itself and these kind of facts
are ignored because of the tribalism but
what's happening you know Trump tweets
it out therefore it's an outright left
you know conservative whatever I don't
think they know exactly what to do I
mean I think there's some educated
decisions that are being made by medical
professionals and then they have to
adjust those based on new statistics
that come in and I don't know if they
have adjusted like the the initial idea
was that there was an X amount of people
that were infected in California yeah it
turns out there's many many many more
and the most recent thought is that
there's somewhere around 400,000 now
there has been some dispute about these
studies you know whether or not these
studies are accurate whether or not the
tests are accurate whether or not you
could get it again whether or not even
matters if you've already had it you
might be able to get it again but
there's no adjustments and no one's
saying hey this is way less deadly than
we thought it was going to be you know
there is this sounds like the problem of
government yeah I've never been one of
these small government types I'm you
know as much as people might want to
argue it with me I lean a little bit
left and a lot of issues like government
programs I think are good things it just
seems like whenever the government
something it's so slow to fix it if it
goes bad or when things change right so
slow to adjust if they need to shift
back they tend to just dump more money
into it if it's not working properly I
want to know why some people just shake
this off that's to me the most for this
it almost seems like you're dealing with
more than one virus it's like you're
dealing with a bunch of different
versions of a virus I think you are I
think they've they've said they found
multiple strains like that it changed a
little bit or something hmm I don't want
to know for sure I know they did say
that about India they said that the the
strain that they have in India is
apparently very different than the
strain they're experiencing in Europe
yeah I think some I heard something
similar about like Washington they found
two strains liberal and conservative
strains yeah yeah yeah it's the crazy
thing to me is the people a lot of Trump
supporters I don't want to blanket every
single one but there's some high-profile
ones that are really acting like since
the beginning they've doubted at every
step of the way and I'm like have you
looked at the spike charts
if you know here's what I say if in New
York City we're seeing thousands more
dead what are they dying of if not some
kind of you know infection I mean you
can call whatever you want you can act
like nothing's going on but we're seeing
huge spikes at camp attention to them
there's fools no matter what you do
there's always gonna be fools so you
know it's obviously a real virus it's
obviously real dangerous it's the little
tribalism yeah it's foolish but it's you
know you know you got to just dismiss
that stuff you can't even debate or
dwell on it but what's interesting to me
is well there's a bunch of parts that
are interesting but what's interesting
to me is like who like George is opened
right and then parts of Montana of opens
there's things that are open in Texas
yeah like it's gonna be interesting to
see what the response is going to be
whether or not they come back online
quicker and their economy builds up
quicker or whether or not they get a
second surge and they've shut down
longer and it winds up being that maybe
should have waited longer and when add
less infection like we just saw a city
of 10 million in China enter lockdown
again did this to what degree I'm not
entirely sure but they've announced
they're you know reopening all the
social distancing measures and certain
closures and stuff like that and they're
saying it's because someone a student I
think they're saying a student from the
u.s. came back
course they're saying that right right
right reignited but there's also a bunch
of studies now about reinfection you
know it's water we don't know and
everyone's freaking out whenever there's
a new disease and everybody's got a
scramble in real time to try to figure
out what the [ __ ] to do about it
and well just weird it out everybody's
weirded out you know no one knows like
what is normal now what is what is
reality the reality we live in like you
see movies now when people hug or shake
hands and you're like ah what are you
doing I've been watching these
commercials you see these commercials
they're all the same where it's like
it's like we're all in this together and
then it shows people banging pots and
pans and it's like we may not be able to
hug anymore but the love is there it's
like all identical but then all of a
sudden older commercial pops up and I
was watching this the other day and it's
like a guy walks up shakes his buddy's
hand pat him on the back and then like
gives his wife a kiss on the cheek and
I'm like that's an old commercial that
is I can tell it's an old campaign yeah
cuz they would not do that most of them
are old because you can't shoot anything
anymore yeah you know I don't know how
i'm curious how they're doing these
commercials where they film new york i
guess they're going out in new york and
filming people actually you know cheer
from their balconies and stuff huh look
you know i think there's a real there's
a real tough question know that a lot of
people want to ignore i think there's a
lot of trump supporters who are pushing
it because they're in favor of reopening
the economy but there's like that
equation of it what point is having
things shut down more damaging then you
know so at a certain point we have to
recognize people can die no matter what
we do well there's a bloomberg not not
the mayor but there's a bloomberg
statistic on the economy that measures
the downside like when when the economy
goes down how many people die because of
it and you could kind of trace it it's
it's very disturbing and when we're
talking about deaths we're talking about
there's something that we can
immediately deal with it's right in
front of us it's a disease it's
happening right now go after it stop it
but the secondary reaction to that in
fact because you're closing the economy
might wind up killing as many people as
you're trying to avoid being killing in
the wall yeah so I don't know they you
went the big story on the UN was that
their advisor said 235 million starving
you know in the next year so unless
things kick back into gear
well hopefully they are going to take
back in the year California's supposed
to open up on May 15th but the governor
has been I don't know if he enjoys it
but it seems like he seems like they
they definitely are comfortable with
being the person they get to say yeah
this is shut down and we're gonna keep
it shut down the authoritarianism is
scary we're the resting people for
[ __ ] going to the park with their
kids yeah you see that tweet from the UK
where they posted the shadows of the two
cops and it was like think going into a
rural area to have a picnic is you'll
get away with it we're gonna look out of
the shadows and find you know where to
god yeah yeah when do I run what you're
in the middle of no having a picnic go
for it here's the thing man they told
[ __ ] China [ __ ] in totally that is
like [ __ ] man well now there is another
story Bill Gates apparently said you
know trying to did a bunch of things
right and now what they're doing is
they're taking that quote and putting it
next to pictures of them welding doors
shut and barricading and when I'm
hanging out with Epstein Oh probably
that's the latest thing is begin really
don't like okay well these people are
sending me all these videos about Bill
Gates now I used to party with Epstein a
lot of people did yeah I wonder how many
of them knew apparently traveled with
Epstein after Epstein had been convicted
oh man
yeah he apparently like a couple years
after he'd been convicted it wasn't like
you didn't know about it right right
have you seen Bill Gates Instagram no
all the comments just flooded with
people saying like globalists and
Illuminati kind of stuff that's gonna
hurt about that I hear it's a lot of
pedophile stuff too right there I don't
know I don't want to I know this is
gonna be really touchy because you got a
lot large with really angry people but
they're saying things like take your
vaccines back we don't want them we
won't wear the mark of the beast you
know a man he's talked about you know
what China did they're they're giving
you these codes on your phone mm-hmm and
you got it if you want to leave if you
leave the town it becomes void I know so
if you're in the city then you can go to
a building they scan it to see if you're
clear and if you are then you're able to
come in you know [ __ ] all that seriously
I think I you know man the amount of
people I've seen argue in favor of this
executive you know these are these
executive orders is pretty scary
yeah I've been scared about that we've
been talking about that quite a bit
lately where I'm saying you you can't
have massive overreaching government
surveillance as a response to a disease
you can't because they're not gonna shut
it off once the disease has a vaccine
they're gonna keep that stuff in place
and you are giving up a massive part of
what it means to be an American well
take me free take a look at the the
social media what's going on with you
know Twitter Facebook they you the CEO
of YouTube we'll start there set on on
CNN basically anyone who says anything
out of line with the World Health
Organization is a bit expandable it's
against our Community Guidelines the
World Health Organization is flip-flop
back and forth you know like several
times on well they're clearly spouting
out Chinese propaganda to protect
particularly in January when they were
saying that according to China there's
no evidence that you could be
transmitted from person to person and
did you know the AP reported at that
time China knew and withheld the
information for six days so the day that
the World Health Organization tweeted
out no evidence according to China of
human human transmission we now know
according to the AP that China did no
and purposefully withheld that you what
you've got going on with China right now
I question whether or not we're getting
close to an act of war and I know that
might be a little exaggerated but
they've got you know this is the story
was published in BuzzFeed news trolls
working either for China or than China
trying to slow down the response in
other regions like Spain Italy Taiwan I
think I think that the buzz be most
specifically about Taiwan sowing
disinformation so it would slow their
response things like that why well I
think China wants Taiwan right well that
they don't that was they're a rogue
provinces that they consider it yeah
well that's why they instructed the
World Health Organization not even
mention the name Taiwan you saw that
video videos crazy weather the head of
the World Health Organization is being
interviewed and in the interview the
woman asks him about Taiwan's response
and he says I think China has done a
great job right and then first he
ignores yes and then he hangs up yeah he
hung up but he did say China and she
said Taiwan and specific and yeah I
think that's when he hung up on and then
he came back said well and she goes
what's get back to question well I think
we've already covered it China's done a
great job like he's clearly avoiding but
why does he think he can do that like
what what what does China have on them
money is it fun is it
kind of funding them I mean you saw what
happen with the NBA and like desert you
know people don't want to give that cold
hard cash they're making a bold bet you
know and I mean you know through Citadis
trap is know so this is I was reading
about this the Atlantic wrote about this
in 2015 are we headed for a war with
China and the city's trap says that
whenever a growing power seeks to upset
the dominant power it results in war and
out of 12 out of 16 times of the past
500 years it has happened so people have
been predicting a us-china war for a
really long time because of this
historical precedent it's not absolute
but it looks like I'm not gonna put on
the historical expert or anything like
that
but it looks extremely probable to me
I've had a lot of people get mad at me
saying that I was fear-mongering by
bringing this up but the u.s. just sent
two warships into the South China Sea
which China considers their own
territory when you look at what China
has been doing in terms of
misinformation clearly lying about the
numbers that you know there
I can't rubber who did this I think may
have been Germany removing China's
numbers from the charts saying they're
not real so China has been misleading
the rest of the world withholding
information on how by the infection is
they sent a strike group an aircraft
carrier through the South China Sea near
Taiwan putting
Japan on alert the us's aircraft carrier
Theodore Roosevelt was disabled because
of the corona virus they evacuate 8% of
the personnel the US doesn't what they
call an elephant walk in Guam where they
have all these bombers then the u.s.
pulls him out because apparently China's
got some kind of weapon that can just
blanket Guam and wipe out our forces
next thing I know we sent a kind of
weapon they know they can do that it's
I'm not entirely sure I'm you know I'm
getting my information from just rating
peripheral stories I'm not a military ro
no got any thought that but it really
does you know so the u.s. just sent two
warships into the South China Sea and I
think they're doing this because one of
the things I read from a military
website was that the strike force is
testing us resolve the last time that
China has done this where they sent a
strike force around Taiwan actually
tried to you know take it in some
fashion the u.s. sent a couple super
carriers and everything calmed down now
our super carriers in the region were
disabled by kovat well didn't China
didn't they go into a group exercise
with Iran
after we killed that guy oh I don't know
yeah there was a group exercise with
China and Iran in the sea that they did
something like some sort of show of
unity right after Trump had that guy's
ass intended do you see what happened
with those Iranian gunboats they were
swarming us the US naval vessels and
then Trump ordered them if they do it
again sink him blow him up Wow do you
know that Venezuela tried commandeering
a civilian yacht a couple weeks ago
what Venezuelan naval ship crashed into
a German owned private cruise liner they
were trying to count as my understanding
of the story because I know a lot of
people are they're not gonna want to
ride that analysis out they were trying
to steal it
so they claimed healin yeah they so I
think the official word from Venezuela
was they thought this was a fake cruise
ship with assassins for Maduro or
something so they ordered it to come
into their their waters because they
weren't Venezuela Venezuelan naval ships
are ramming it sank itself yeah I heard
about that yeah yeah and so then
sometime after Donald Trump deploys two
US naval vessels to near venez what near
Venezuelan waters which he says are for
drug related operations I'm not gonna
like I know I'm a lot of people gonna
get heated saying you know you're
talking about yeah yeah all I know is
that's what was reported who knows what
that means or what leads to but needless
to say with it you know look Russia's
withholding wheat exports several
European countries have have closed
their borders within the Schengen area
their withhold their people are trying
to hoard food and we just had a
full-page ad in in the New York Times
Sunday edition I think was from Tyson
saying the food supply chain is breaking
and we're getting ready for a major
shortage of food you know they had a
killed two million chickens Wow because
they didn't have anybody to butcher them
here's what here's here's my concern
when you have these nation-states
shoring up their borders even within the
European Union that was crazy to me when
you see Germany and France and Austria
closing their borders to each other then
you get these warships making these
movements you get people desperate for
food you see Venezuela ramming into a
cruise ship I say this it could be that
we're hyper focused on it because we're
bored we don't only pay attention to the
stuff we normally pay attention to
celebrity gossip in politics now that
we're not doing anything we're really
focused I was happening in international
territory or perhaps it's that we're
getting desk
and were scared as the economy tanks
well if it wasn't for mutually assured
destruction I would say yeah we're
probably moving into a place of war but
you have two nuclear superpowers like
China and the US it's like what you know
what do they do what are you gonna do
you're gonna one guy gotta launch a
missile the other guys gonna launch them
and so like what are they gonna do yeah
are they gonna go into a full-scale warm
wipe out everyone on the planet cuz
that's what would happen I think so I do
the thing is who would be more willing
to wipe out a giant chunk of the
population would it be China or would it
be the United States I don't think it'd
be the United States I think it'd be
China and I think it really depends on
how strange they are for resources and
whether or not they're really going to
lose the the the the difficult look in
China when this broke out what we saw
videos of them barricading people in
their homes welding their doors shut
yeah the doctor whistleblower there's
one story of Iran a journalist was
calling out all of these things
disappears for a month comes back a
month later all happy like governments
great we love them really yeah we know
we know what they do we've seen we've
seen videos now this could be propaganda
you know cuz I'm in America so of course
I'm getting this information maybe the
u.s. is trying to you know build us up
but I think you take a look at that kind
of behavior the willingness to do
anything by any means necessary and at
what point do you get one person is in
charge saying I will not be the captain
of a ship that sinks you know I look -
well I don't want to get super political
in American history but I view it as
you've got a leader of a country and as
people are looking at him he says this
will be the year my country ceases to
exist if that presses a button I will
not be the lead you know I will not be
the person with its stain it's hard to
know though because it could be a leader
saying I will not be the person who
destroys the world I would rather go
down in history as the you know failure
of my country I I think you back
somebody into a corner and you get
fighter flight
I don't trust chumps Trump's
decision-making in that regard either no
I don't you know I just I don't trust
anybody's decision-making but anybody
who won't admit that he said one thing
when we saw this infection maybe I know
the fact that he said he was being
sarcastic that was so dumb and if you're
that same person and we want you to be
in charge of this decision whether or
not we go to war I mean obviously you
have to have the support
Congress but this but you know this this
is you know the the the disinfectant
story is the one of the weirdest and
most difficult things to actually grasp
I think you just got caught rambling
that's it
yep setup so a South Park where Cartman
pretends like he has Tourette's so so
Cartman finds out that people with
Tourette's just say all these things so
he's like if I pretend to have this I
can say whatever I want and then
eventually he loses his filter and
starts saying a bunch of ridiculous
things like he starts admitting to like
you know touching his cousin or
something camp and he's like why am I
saying this oh no I've lost my filter
Donald Trump that's what he here's how I
see it
he heard something from these experts he
didn't understand it he has no filter
and so he just asked this thing here's
here's my challenge with it is there
such thing as a stupid question
yes there is can you eat glass right
that's a stupid question well I don't
some like performers eat glass they
don't really know really well so he chew
up candy glass yeah here's here's this
here's the struggle here's a struggle
what is it disinfectant how do you
interpret what he said and here's what
Trump supporters immediately fired back
with there is h2o to nebulization
therapy and they they pulled up an
article from it was posted msn.com April
tenth one of the treatments they're
looking at for kovat is to take hydrogen
peroxide through a nebulizer into your
lungs
that's a disinfectant into your body for
a cleaning I don't think Trump was going
for that I think the guy mentioned we
have bleach and alcohol in Trump was
like I wonder if you could you know
possibly get in their body through the
addiction as a clean and yeah I'm right
look well what's really interesting that
came out of this was Twitter banned an
account that is a publicly traded
biotech account that has a legitimate
therapy you know when someone has been
incubated when they've been when they're
on a respirator they can send UV light
through that tube and actually kill some
of the bad bacteria in the lungs now the
the video that shows how they do it
shows like the tube and this likes an
animated thing which shows the lungs
they banned them right they banned a
publicly traded biotech company
just just I don't know if they banned
them because they think that in some way
this supports what Trump was saying or
if someone just pulled the trigger too
quickly I mean who's doing this over
here I think you have a bunch of [ __ ]
kids that are making decisions whether
or not something gets banned or not
something gets reported like someone
report I'm just guessing some reports
that says look these [ __ ] idiots are
saying that Donald Trump's right you can
get light in there ban it make it count
okay we set here yes with Jack and Vidya
Vidya and I don't think we got a
definitive answer necessarily we got a
you know thank you for your feedback I
think we got an answer in terms of what
Jack wants in terms of he I think Jack
is a legitimately honest guy who is
trying to manage things at scale and I
think that's almost impossible I don't
think she or numbers that are coming in
and he's trying to do wild-west Twitter
now this is his concept of having a
Twitter that's just wide open we could
do anything and then having like a
regular sort of moderated Twitter
there's a there's a name I can say right
now a name if I say a name right now
Candyman this this video will be pulled
from YouTube do you know that really I
can say one guy's name Alex Jones no I'm
not don't don't say it if you know it is
don't say it I'm not gonna start with I
don't think I should even do that really
I've had my video taken down and I've
been told to write it down
he wrote its own form you sure yeah
right yeah just write it down if you say
this name your video will be taken out
they take it on c-span they've taken
down Fox News really I'm Hitler no I'm
warning enough say this name the
company's been unsuspended if you will
unsuspended for that so yeah so somebody
probably [ __ ] up there's probably a
kid that my handwriting is awful that's
okay
do not say that name I'm not kidding
with you man do not say that name I
don't even know who that is he is the
he's a I can I can scram to you he's a
CIA he worked he worked for the CIA I
guess he is accused of being the
whistleblower the Ukraine whistleblower
oh and if you say his name you will get
taken down wow this is that so that
seems like
how come how come news will get you
taken down yeah
makes you wonder right how come a
biotech company with a legitimate
product gets taken down now you got
yourselves a restored yeah I think that
biotech company somebody [ __ ] up I
think I think you have too much I think
from what Adam curry was explaining to
me is that there's a bunch of kids that
work for Twitter and they work for a lot
of these other companies and they're
there were the ones responsible for
whether or not something gets banned if
something gets taken down you know the
zubi story the okay dude story right
right which is just bonkers let's look
for people so this can be standalone
zubi who is a British guy we've talked
about this on the podcast where he's
been a guest in the podcast he's a
rapper
very very intelligent interesting guy
doesn't even swear he's very polite he's
a really nice guy so he gets in some
sort of an interaction with someone on
Twitter and this person says I bet I
sleep with more women than you he says
okay dude that's it he got a new hand
banded for a long period of time like
weeks or whatever the [ __ ] it is I don't
know how long you get suspended for
something like that but then he asked
for it to be reviewed and they upheld it
yeah they said yes you can't say oh okay
dude no I don't know if he was talking
to a trans woman didn't either yeah he
didn't either yeah I know it he didn't
know is that what it is is that what the
case was I that's my understanding of
the story yeah well he didn't even know
right he just saw someone and said okay
dude you know what the problem is this
idea of approved truth what YouTube
calls authoritative sources so I know
I'm pretty hard on YouTube but this
doesn't involve Facebook as well that
name I sent you this book will delete
your post without notice if you type it
Wow
so here's what I did tried it I typed I
just I I said something like I heard of
a man from Dubuque an orthodontist named
who has five kids and he's in his
mid-50s I did that because that in no
way describes who that person is right
not not only do Facebook delete it they
deleted it without telling me it was
just erased from the site gone so it's
some sort of filter that's in place no
no somebody manually did it it was there
for a while and then somebody came in or
somehow so so do you know what happened
with CNN Chris Cuomo getting--getting
kovat you know they faked that whole
thing right what do you mean they faked
it so
Chris Cuomo was spotted 30 minutes from
his house on a property with a new cut
with a new construction being built yes
a steel frame a guy on a bike saw him
Chris Cuomo they got into it
como goes on his radio show and says I
don't want this jackass on a fat tire
bike coming up to me I should tell him
what I want the guy in the bike says he
called the cops and said he threatened
me
so this basically confirms the encounter
Chris Cuomo then then shot a segment for
CNN of him emerging from his basement
like this is what I've been dreaming of
finally getting out of my basement see
my kids but he was witnessed seeing his
kids somewhere else with his kids yeah
so you even had that you even had Ben
Smith the New York Times call this out
saying he Ben Smith used to be the
editor-in-chief of BuzzFeed news now
he's a media columnist for an airtime
said something The effect of it's it's
like shocking how CNN is aligning this
whole controversy there they're kinda
like it didn't happen
everybody knows Cuomo faked it yeah he
wasn't in quarantine he was out
presumably he was at two women and three
kids so we can we can assume it was his
wife and his kids whatever I bring that
up because you got a couple other
moments right you've got brian Stelter
on you on his show saying that we got to
channel the anger for the people yeah
that he was saying that journalists need
to do that yep which is which is you
know I basically said so you're
admitting your rage bait you know yes I
saw you did that I was glad that you
said that like finally they're admitting
it right right right I mean look it's no
secret I'm gonna rag on on the media I
worked for these companies and I've seen
them slowly getting worse and worse with
everything I want to see Brian scream
you want to see Brian scream yeah I
think like him enraged would be a dog
like I don't I wonder how much anger he
can muster I can't I can't so what so
here's a point I was getting to CNN's
called an authoritative source yeah
they're lying in our faces I mean you
just had the Joe Biden thing for I don't
know if you've talked about this yet
but if you go to google play and look up
Larry King's show from 1993 you will see
there so actually I checked many of the
different months what people noticed was
that one episode was missing August 11th
1993 the episode where Joe Biden's
accuser called in saying my daughter had
a problem with a prominent senator knows
Joe Biden's what accusers mom because
yeah what did I say I said accuser all
right yeah his accuser is his mom write
that up so it's gone yes so I went
through google play and there's
certainly were other episodes that were
presumably missing typically mondays
where I was soon I would assume that you
know Larry King had a day off or
something the 11th was a Wednesday why
was this missing
why did CNN why were they scooped on
their own story they had this evidence
apparently this was this was news so
when you look at what CNN's been doing
admitting that they're doing rage
journalism you get people like Jim
Acosta but isn't that like what Brian
said what's brian Stelter Stelter
Stelter isn't he just that is that this
his own opinion you know i mean it's not
that they're admitting that they're
doing rage journalism it's he's saying
that they should do that right isn't
that what it was
how'd he set it on twitter right yeah
yeah it was somewhat from his show was
it I'm a thank you I think was reliable
sources tweeting it out yeah and you
know look I may be hyperbolic or
whatever cuz I got my opinions on CNN
and all that but take a look at someone
like Jim Acosta he stands up he argues
with the president that's not what
journalist was supposed to do you know
if you want to ask the president
question he gives you an answer if he if
you have the opportunity for a follow-up
you do and then you write your story and
you fact check them you write your story
and say Donald Trump here's what he told
us here's the truth
that's what journalists used to do now
you've got this idea of channeling the
rage for the people what that means is
it's something I've seen in activist
circles where I was explained to me that
what people are looking for is someone
to strike down a symbol of what they
view as their enemy or the cause of
their problems so the reasons why
someone like Jim Acosta would do so well
he would get so many followers
constantly doing this it's not that he's
asking any real questions or actually
challenging the president it's that the
people who don't like Trump see him as
striking a symbol down it doesn't matter
if he's telling you the truth or not now
you get performative journalism where
Chris Cuomo pretends to come out of his
basement where you know you get people
standing up with the White House
Correspondents or at the press
conference is just arguing instead of
actually asking questions and then
YouTube Facebook and Twitter say this is
the truth we deem it so YouTube now puts
them among other outlets on the front
page of the website guaranteeing
hundreds of millions of views meanwhile
independent commentators like myself we
actually get hurt in the algorithm if
you go to my channel they only show you
fox news if you want to watch me then
you are guaranteed in the sidebar the
next
we'll be foxnews they prop up all of
these channels David Pakman for instance
you get MSNBC Jimmy Dore Fox News I
don't understand why they're gonna send
Jimmy's you know lefty followers to Fox
News but they're doing seemingly
everything their power to make sure
individuals like myself and other
commentators are struck down while
channels like CNN Fox and MSNBC are
propped up even though we know that they
put out fake news but isn't that but
because of the algorithm though and do
you think that algorithm is engineered
it wasn't towards those mainstream so
absolutely we can see we can see when it
happened it was May of last year you
looked at my analytics around the time
these smear pieces came out arguing that
there was a rabbit hole where if you
watch one kind of contents all you get
mm-hmm it's a very very misleading way
of framing what was really going on and
I'm surprised that YouTube just bent
over for this you basically have
YouTube's competition these media
outlets using their media wait to hurt
YouTube in ad sales so YouTube says you
got it we'll give you front page access
we'll guarantee you you know people
watch your content right but they're
doing that because that content is very
popular and that generates ad revenue
well are why would out I would say no
actually I would argue against that well
okay but listen like Tucker Carlson for
example you ought to know he's hugely
popular absolutely if you have a tucker
carlson video that's gonna generate
millions of views absolutely so youtube
within their best interests I'm talking
about Allison Cammarata is anybody
really google searching you on YouTube
Allison camarones opinion on all day I
don't think so I think I don't know who
that is right exactly and so you
wouldn't be searching for it Tucker of
course we know all right so you're
saying it's the the channel in general
not just someone who's popular like Sean
Hannity or Tucker Carlson they as very
famous personalities very obviously do
get you know more get more naturally
yeah so people are searching for Tucker
all day and night Hannity and Rachel
Maddow things like that right but if you
if you look at house what YouTube has
even said to CNN they prop up
authoritative sources yes if you search
for a new story guess who you're gonna
get if you google search you know taro
Reed Joe Biden you're gonna get CNN do
you doing that though because they're
trying to get rid of conspiracy theories
yes yeah
that's right reason yeah they're trying
to get like I understand what they're
saying in terms of so like the CEO of
YouTube when she said that they're gonna
go with the World Health Organization I
don't think it's a good idea to go with
the World Health Organization cuz it
seems like it's a very corrupt
organization but I do understand this
desire to go towards respected and
establish medical professionals
respected and established medical
professionals have a protocol for
dealing with coronavirus we should
listen to them
right yeah absolutely and there's a lot
of wacky [ __ ] online that are trying to
say that it's not a real virus and that
it's 5g and there's like all that kind
of stuff is dangerous you know what they
told me don't you think absolutely
absolutely but they told me they publish
that etheral guidelines very early on I
did a video about this January 23rd when
they first started locking down I did a
segment talking about what's going on
and I actually didn't think it was a big
deal this was before anybody was really
covering it I mean this is young
Pietschmann was happening and YouTube
fully monetized it can so I'm I have a
thing on YouTube called
self-certification where when I upload a
video they ask me does your video
contain any of the following my videos
are always clean family friendly I don't
swear and I was approved video monetized
a week later they implemented a new
change without tongue anyone anything
anyone talking about coronavirus was
instantly d monetized D ranked possibly
had your video is harder to find things
like that and it wasn't until about a
couple weeks ago they overturned these D
rankings on my channel they told me
before they published the guidelines
you cannot say these things one of which
was that it may have emerged from a bio
lab now we have on April I think I think
was a 16th a former Clinton
administration NSC staffer saying that
Occam's razor suggests the most likely
place that this came from was breaking
out of an bio lab it was a story by Bret
Baier over Fox News where he said
according to sources he has who have
overseen the documents they believe that
China was trying to essentially prove
their their their worth with American
bio research by racing to do this
development and there was a breach and
this resulted in in the covert outbreak
that's that's Fox News and CNN CNN's run
run multiple segments saying this when I
talk about it I get D ranked do you
monetize confirmed they say you can't
talk about the stem CNN Ken they're
authoritative you can't even if I use
them as a source even if I say like so
if I what I try to do is you know way
the sources how good are they
bret baier that's a good source I mean
Bret Baier is one of the last true news
people I don't I'm not somebody who
follows him too much but he's a straight
news guy he put his name on this and
that that says a lot to me
you don't gotta like the guy you like
Fox News but CNN also ran the story
saying US intelligence now believes or
I'm sorry they're investigating whether
this claim is it has merit we also had a
story from the Washington Post that
asked the same question even got a
professor from Rutgers University to say
it's very possible the story actually
emerged because at south china universe
was I think South China University in
Beijing released a paper saying that
somebody was doing experiments on bat
bats with coronavirus and one of the
bats spilled blood on him and peed on
him and he had a self quarantine for 14
days being that the Wuhan CDC I think
it's a CDC is about you know 300 meters
away from though from the food market it
seems like that was a likely scenario
they eventually retract that retracted
that paper it's a fuckton movie scene
totally so look all right it's not it's
not me saying it I understand what
you're saying
but you know what I get I get knocked
down for this I understand about it I
understand but I think in their defense
some of this has to be that they're
managing at scale some of this has to be
the fact that millions of videos are
uploaded every day and they have to keep
this dense disinformation from spreading
out of control when you have all these
[ __ ] nut jobs they're saying this is
5g is uneven a virus it's radiation
sickness someone sent me a guy that I
really like sent me this video of this
doctor that seems like he's got
schizophrenia or something he's talking
about this is a plasma disease caused by
radiation and I'm like oh [ __ ] in Christ
he imagined I've gotten so many people
hitting me up Jim you got to talk about
5g oh god you know how many people hit
me up when 4G came out
listen 5g is a thing right it's a it's a
new bandwidth for cell phones it's going
to be really fast let's go
going to be in your phone so the
question is like okay all this stuff's
flying through the air there's all these
signals to the air what effect do they
have on the human body that's a good
question
that's a good question but to say that
that's responsible for this coronavirus
thing it's [ __ ] crazy totally if
you're saying they don't have any effect
and here's why I go okay this is why you
don't need to be worried about UHF or V
or whatever different waves that are
flying around through the air Wi-Fi and
people are worried about all that kind
of [ __ ] they're really concerned that
this does have some sort of effect on
human beings they think that in fact
cell phone signals have an effect on
bees right that was one of the primary
theories about the drop in bee
populations
yeah colony collapse now these cell
phone signals are interfering with these
bees ability to communicate but to say
that it's the [ __ ] corona virus like
Jesus Christ and then someone had a meme
little Lil Duval had a meme that he put
up on his Instagram and I retweeted it
five g's only in five countries you
[ __ ] right this guy [ __ ] has spread
across the whole world he you really
think it's five G it's they I believe
YouTube has to step in and they have to
do something when [ __ ] like that is so
egregious is so preposterous so the
question is where do they draw that line
if it would be nice if they could watch
all your videos and say oh well today
was a really reasonable guy they do okay
but yeah they do they really know that
yeah they do they really they literally
guy who's doing that yes who is a
hundred percent dedicated to watching
everything you do you put out a lot of
[ __ ] kind I do how much content you
put out every day so if you had to guess
rat an average right now as of the past
few months up to about three three hours
and forty minutes per day so you got a
guy it's dedicated at YouTube his job is
what do you do
I'm the Tim pool guy I'm just so first
probably not like that specific but I do
have a partner manager I do have every
single video I put out on my foot my
mate mama my main channel is reviewed
100% of them on they just recently
introduced my other two channels so I
have I have a total of three channels
under my name where I put out around ten
to twelve separate videos per day for a
total about three hours and forty
minutes they what they do so if I upload
a video
it gets reviewed through something so I
first self-certify I say this video has
no swearing it has no you know extreme
imagery or anything like that if someone
watches it and D monetizes it I then
contact Google and they reverse it for
me so I actually have someone who fixes
this if there's an issue they watch them
they watch every episode they watch
every episode every episode that bonkers
so you got a guy who that's there don't
think I don't think it's necessarily one
person but a team of freaks my
understanding is it is California based
and so so here's where I look I'm I
think you did a very very awesome thing
I wouldn't have a show I'd be working I
was working for a Disney company and I
did not like it and I was able to leave
and start my own business and I'm rather
successful with it and it's because of
YouTube and it's because they view me as
trustworthy they you know I've known
them for a long time they've worked with
me it's not perfect
the challenge is fundamental human
rights and in the end the collapse of
the media industry when we have news
outlets that so it was I give you an
example you post this on Instagram that
people were calls for poisoning
you know disinfectant ingestion had gone
up after Trump's comments right that's
not true it's fake news I fell for two I
tweeted out I tweeted the George George
Carlin quote the one that's uh think
about how stupid the average person is
and realize half of them are stupider
than that sure enough it turns out they
faked the story the real story is that
since the start of the pandemic people
have been buying more cleaner than
normal so statistically with more people
having cleaner they're more likely now
to accidentally ingest it and since
March the calls have been going up the
New York Daily News one of the main
purveyors of the story tacked on after
Donald Trump's comments unrelated
unrelated unrelated so here's the
problem if the Daily News if CNN if if
Fox if MSNBC if these outlets are going
to do these things in a desperate bid to
stay alive as their as their methodology
fails and YouTube is going to give them
a preferential access which is what
they've done then we're in serious
trouble but they don't give the Daily
News preference no no like a channel the
main networks I don't think I
Regus right here's here's one that
really grossed me out was CNN I believe
they tweeted one of the reporters at CNN
tweeted that Elon Musk has not supplied
all the ventilators that he promised and
then Elon said are you aware that
Twitter has a search feature and then he
starts retweeting all of these different
hospitals showing the ventilators people
thanking him it has a Tesla logo on it
and and and it was the hospitals are
requested them specifically and they
were specific parameters so you don't
CNN did argued semantics the article
that was written to to prove they were
right was that those aren't ventilators
real ventilators are invasive
ventilators that go in your body and
cpad a CPAP is a ventilator is a
ventilator as is a BiPAP what they're
called non-invasive or not intrusive
that's such a [ __ ] gross way to just
decide what you tweeted and so
journalists are supposed to help you
understand what's going on in them yes
not confuse it there the goal of making
money right that's what that's what it
is right it's about clickbait absolutely
you can clickbait that the smartest man
in the world [ __ ] up and didn't give
the ventilators you want what the
scariest thing is CNN anybody's network
anyone any of these networks can make a
fake story get a million views a day
later apologize retract and they keep
all the money they made they don't got
to give it back so they're actually
actively incentivized I'm not saying
they're sitting there you know trolling
a mustache man like let's write a fake
story but they know that if they do they
get paid and they less so what they were
you know what the fake news gets a
million hits the retraction gets 30k we
get paid for both so this is an
editorial review fail or editors are not
reviewing these articles that are being
written by journalists I think they're
all swimming in a toilet circling you
know down to the drain because what
happens is somebody so I saw story
written I think it was an op-ed for the
Washington Post or something about
Trump's alligator moat as fake news that
was never real alligator moat right
right so this story from 2017 that Trump
talked about putting alligators in a
moat around the southern border or
something was like it's ridiculous but
here's what happens you write a fake
story they wrote that yeah so that was
his idea too
do that it's been a while my
understanding of the story was that a
source familiar with you know Trump's
thinking said that Trump had discussed
an alligator moat and I'm like even if
Trump did isn't it obvious it was a joke
they take they run their money good luck
alligators would it take to guard the
southern border thousand miles or
whatever but now now we see this pop up
again and so I'll tell you what man the
scariest thing is how these social the
social networks remove like we talked
about last year they remove a certain
point of view like this biotech company
they default on what is authoritative
and the authoritative falls in one
direction almost every single time Falls
left right yes so you know I can't tell
you how many how many stories I've gone
through where it's like you know that
Peter Navarro story where Trump said to
the journalist you're a nasty nasty
reporter and everything yes
what you don't see was the full context
where the guy kept goading Trump for
like 10-15 minutes and then finally
Trump snaps at him and they take that
one soundbite and say look at Trump just
being a dick it's like well yes Trump's
got no filter and he gets mad but they
cut out the entire exchange where this
dude was poking and prodding and like
really just insulting the guy so this
guy Peter Navarro he's saying things
like why are you trying to give people
hope don't you think that offering up
false hope is is wrong and Trump's like
no I don't think so I think was in
cleric win yeah so you get a you get a
guy that keeps you know goading him and
arguing with them and that's what the
point is being earlier it's these people
is for CNN and whatever Network have
realized hey we're going to get ratings
but let me tell you they say first of
all that way of communicating is [ __ ]
terrible it's second only to the
terribleness that in those late-night
news shows where they have three
different people like with three to the
screen separated into three chunks and
this person on the right is arguing with
this person left and the moderator is
trying to keep everybody in order and
everyone's talking over everybody and
everyone's looking for a soundbite and
everyone's looking to get their shots in
before the buzzer because there's like a
bell coming right the commercial runs it
is the dumbest way to really explore a
complicated idea right and second only
to that is these [ __ ] things where
this the president stands the podium and
people yell things out someone
called it to come flu someone called it
to come flu do you do not denounce that
this racist word come flu and Trump said
who said it yeah I don't know I heard I
don't know you know I loved when one of
the journalists asked Trump of the price
of oil he goes where's it at and the guy
says oh I don't know but I know know
where's the price of oil the reporter
says I don't know then why are you
asking next question yeah these people
are don't they don't know what their
look I've sat in these rooms at press
conferences I have I have stood in front
of public officials as they prepared an
announcement and I know exactly I've
talked to these producers I've talked to
the journalists they're like ask
question what should I ask just just ask
anything so they they've I've been
thrown in front of people like ask him
something I'm like what am I supposed to
ask him ask him anything
make something up because they want you
to get that screen time so they can say
it's theirs
well it's also someone like Jim Acosta
for example don't you think there's an
inclination when someone gets a certain
amount of attention to lean towards that
attention this is your base now these
are the people that are supporting you
and you find it with like online
commentators and where what's really
weird is one like a person used to be
left and then you see they get them
getting a little bit of love from the
right and they start like entering over
there and their comments and they get
more and more attention and then they
just jump ship and the inverse like
people who were leaning towards more
right wing talking points got attacked
for it and then immediately came out in
support of certain politicians yes yeah
yes you see people leaning towards what
gets them the most amount of love right
and for Jim Acosta like that it seems
like he gets a lot of love for attacking
this guy because he's talking for them
for the people at home I wish I could
ask the president what the [ __ ] are you
doing there's kind of get him Jim and
this is the it's it's and it's it's
scary when I go on reddit for instance
and they've basically purged 90% of any
pro-trump point of view really it's gone
man I I pull up I pull up reddit and
what do I get
it's it's it's all lefty commentary if
you go to like our slash politics which
has I think you know 5 to 6 million subs
they use left-wing activist websites as
new sources
so it's not a place for real political
discussion it's a place to get your
biases confirmed the same the same is
true for the Donald Trump subreddit
which has been basically purged you know
they like they used to have a real
subreddit called the Donald and then oh
yeah they killed it they killed it
because they thought that it was filled
with trolls right they killed it because
they claimed the Trump supporters were
threatening cops
I'm not joking that's that's the story
does that sound a little strange to you
that Trump supporters would be anti cop
to me in any sense
zowie that doesn't make any sense that
you would use that as an example for an
s to see a necessary move to ban the
entire subreddit it seems like so it's
not banned what is it it was quarantined
quarantine so you can no longer you can
no longer search for it
the only way to access it is to be
subscribed until I give your email
they've since abandoned that and created
a new website that Donald dot win you go
there you're gonna hear only good things
about the president and while there are
certainly things you'll just like any
rational person would disagree with I
think a healthy discourse tries you know
you want to you want to see the counter
points you want to see the positive
points you want to better understand you
know is there a real reason why Donald
Trump did something or is he just an
idiot and if you're only getting one
side of it your your view of the world
is just totally and it used to be like
the Wild West right it was pretty wild
until like 2016 is very little
moderating reddit is so incredibly easy
to manipulate and control at
ridiculously easy that you know I
remember and what year was may be 2015
political operatives were seeking ways
to prop up politicians manipulating
reddit's algorithms because users have
direct control of it I'll just tell you
it's ridiculously easy to do like
insanely easy they've since made it more
difficult but one person with a hamp
with it with ten cell phones and you
could own the front page of Reddit very
very easily that's crazy since then
we've seen accusations of and I think
it's fair to say you know in my
experience I know that this you know
tends to exist the sock puppetry when
someone runs multiple accounts prying to
be different people to create the
perception of consensus yes and that's
what they do that's really really common
super now I know a guy who is a
at reddit and told me this one account
had nine different people mm-hmm or nine
what one person had nine different
accounts yeah they were using to attack
this guy and you can can so the way
right it works for those I don't know is
you upvote and downvote something if it
has more up votes it moves up if it has
more down votes it does it's elite it
appears so if you create a bunch of
different accounts using proxy servers
or you know other IP manipulation you
can make sure your post is always in
front now was there a concern that the
Donalds
that the donald reddit site was being
manipulated that so that they were
basically just using it early on yeah
yeah there was a so the donald post
would frequently hit the front page of
all so if you go to Reddit and you want
to see every subreddit the Donald was
always on top sometimes it was so active
that depends on who you ask right or
because people were manipulating it one
of the other I it's that there's a good
argument for both I don't have the
evidence to give you a definitive answer
I think it's fair to say that Trump
supporters will smash the upload button
make sure those posts always fly to the
top because they're very enthusiastic
very enthusiast it's also possible that
somebody had a bot you know botnet that
was you know yeah yeah but one of the
things that the Donald got in trouble
for I think was they would they would do
what's called a sticky post so that
means if you went there one post was
always on top of their page so the
supporters knew top-voted guaranteeing
it would get a lot of traction but we
actually saw this is the craziest thing
the CEO of Reddit manipulated in the
database someone's comment who was a
trump supporter it's actually this is
like could you imagine the CEO did this
the editor he went into the database the
hard database for someone's comment and
changed what they said what yeah he
apologized for it saying I got new I got
angry someone called him a pedo so he
was like oh yeah and he went in oh
that's right I remembered this he
actually edited the words to make that
personal piece of [ __ ] like anti-trump
or something yeah so I'll tell you what
man look there's there's a there's a lot
of arguments you can make about policy
and the right way to solve these
problems but I go on the front I go I
open reddit I'm browsing through it and
I see these comments from pee
that clearly do not understand what's
going out with these protests that
people want the economy to reopen and I
try and talk to my friends about it and
it seems like they're trapped because I
think you know it's like you were
mentioning how people drift towards what
gets them the most love mm-hmm but now
it's not just famous people it's not
just people on social media it's
everybody who does that and they don't
want that worldview broken well they
also don't want to lose the respect of
their friends who are also subscribing
to that same ideology yeah yeah that's
it's it's part of politics well over
here in California if you're if you're
not left-wing if you don't you know just
instantaneously when when there's an
issue instantaneously side with the left
you get chastised and you get called a
racist or you could call the Nazi or you
called a a Trump supporter or yeah you
can't even have a rational perspective
on things you can't say something like
in hindsight it was a good idea that
Donald Trump closed off travel from
China because it was coming from there
and a lot of people are calling him
racist it turned out to be a good move
and then they've shut it down from a lot
of different places as well you can't
say that so so yeah right so the first
thing Trump does is the the task force
two days later the travel ban Joe Biden
says the last thing we need is Trump's
is in a phobia then on March I think
12th Trump suspends travel from Europe
Joe Biden says a travel ban won't stop
this April third Biden says actually
Trump was right about that now Joe
Biden's launching ads saying Trump
didn't go far enough now Nancy Pelosi is
saying Trump should have banned
Americans from coming back in did you
ever see that video when Nancy Pelosi is
talking about telling people to go to
Chinatown oh yeah it worse that video is
[ __ ] insane and when they confront
her on it on Fox News I think was Chris
Wallace on Fox News was talking to her
about it
she's saying well the record will show
that I was saying don't be rude to
Chinese people now you were down there
encouraging it yes and the record will
show she's such an ineffective speaker
it's so bizarre that she got to a
position of power because she's right
she's so disingenuous and so fake in the
way she communicates maybe especially on
those shows maybe she's just old maybe
she was better before I don't know maybe
right that's the Addyson question this
is oh man
he had the Biden question that dudes not
even he's not even here anymore he
so weird it's so weird they're
pretending that it's okay that this is
gonna be fine
but the way they're defending him over
these allegations is this the creepy
thing under whirring the allegation you
see Alyssa Milano when she yes what what
is this yeah she said deserves due
process yeah other times what about all
the other people this is it's it's you
know I can't predict what's gonna happen
there's a lot of things that are
changing you know right now that's gonna
affect whether or not Trump wins the
Republicans win or lose but what about
is this weird thing that he wants to do
where he wants to insist on a woman of
color as a vice presidential nominee
wants to I think he said I'm not sure he
said woman of color I think he said he's
guaranteeing it to me a woman and he's
looking at a woman of color I'm not
entirely sure to me that's that but
that's absurd I mean if you're if you've
if you've got a good candidate I think
you know it I don't care what they look
like what their skin color is their race
gender I know a lot of people on the
Left view that is like short-sighted
because and and I think there's there's
decent reasons to talk about how
identity plays you know into how you
view the world and the policies you want
to implement I just think it's dangerous
to create that kind of yeah we're not
talking about prom queen we're talking
about someone who actually has a real
important job
I shouldn't pick them based on what part
of the world their ancestors are from or
what gender they are
that's really I would actually say on a
scale of one to a hundred that's not
near like the top 50 but I think it is
fair to say that there's a real reason
why that would play a factor play a role
like you you've got a lot of people who
have never experienced certain things
and that includes the left and one of
the big problems even politics is what
we see coming from the left is really
based on urban living and from
conservatives on more likely to be rural
living so when you see people on the
left argue for like rent strikes and
things like that
well yeah you're in a you're in cities
where you're predominantly renters so
that's your big issue it doesn't
resonate the same with people who live
in areas where they primarily own their
homes or if you're talking about the
Second Amendment like obviously people
in cities they tend to be liberal they
want gun control yeah because you've got
a very very dense population gun
accidents probably are an issue and
you've got cops within a minutes notice
you live in a rural area the cops are
for you
it's a way you need to protect yourself
so this this divide creates a difficulty
in creating policy for the entirety of
the country I could pawn I personally
would never play someone's like racial
identity or gender in the top priorities
but I do think it's it is fair to point
out that you know a black woman is gonna
understand things about life in the
black community that a white man is not
going to that doesn't mean you give him
a job because of it you can point out
the perspectives will be different I
agree with both those things right
that's a good point too in terms of the
overall country is so enormous and it's
so different and varied like to find
some common ground
amongst everyone is so incredibly
difficult so it's a contest of who's got
the bigger bigger bucket yeah big our
electoral bucket yeah that's a good way
of putting it - yeah yeah it seems like
but either way there's so many people
that are just gonna vote left to get
Trump out of office they don't care
you're gonna elect a guy with dementia
you gotta pull up this article stay
alive Joe Biden by the Atlantic no I'm
not kidding when did they put this ha
man was a couple weeks ago maybe it's
called stay alive Joe Biden all
something and then she says something
like all we need is your corporeal form
and it's it's not not only arguing that
we just need Joe Biden's body but it
actually kind of argues he's a bad
candidate and it's like it doesn't
matter though it doesn't because we just
don't like Trump well they're right
about that he's a bad candidate Biden oh
yeah they could have done so much better
with Budaj edge with khlo Bashar with
did they're terrified so Gabbard they're
terrified of Bernie Sanders and Andrew
yang I think probably freaks him out a
little bit too I was uh I'm a big fan of
Tulsi and followed by yang and a lot of
people didn't like that because you know
I rag on Democrats all the time it's
like more I'll fully admit you can
criticize me all day and night I'm you
know much see Pelosi and shift Nadler
and like you know the problems we have
with them and I'm not a fan of their
policies I think they go you know they
either do nothing but you know within
that I saw Andrew yang and his website
the list of things he's gone through
what he's thought about was was insane I
mean the dude had a policy for
everything when I was a brilliant guy
absolutely and
also not a politician so his approach is
going to be from a guy who's an
entrepreneur right a guy who looks at it
in terms of problems to fix you could
you can argue there's a similar thing
there with Trump being a businessman but
yang's listo his he's a comprehensive
list of policy positions was it was to
me I was like I like it I do totally not
that guy the thing about Trump is a
giant personality right
whereas yang is a really reasonable
person yeah for me you know Tull sees
anti-war stance was paramount I think
the US has wasted too much money we've
got people arguing for you know fix the
pipes in Flint and I'm like right on
let's stop building weapons and doing
deployments and trying to control these
foreign countries and start working
within America and I think that but
there's a reason why a lot of moderates
and conservatives like Tulsi and it's
that it's it's kind of America first
right you know and why are we applying
so much of our resources and time and
energy to these foreign countries we
shouldn't be doing that well also she's
earned that perspective with two tours
of duty overseas she served and you know
the Armed Forces she's been a
congresswoman for six years she just
stands a lot about how this works I
disagree I disagree with her on to some
of her domestic policy issues nuclear
energy and well you what is her stance
on nuclear she opposes it well I don't
want to speak for her cuz I'm trying to
be very careful but negative view on
nuclear energy and nuclear energy is
different than Three Mile Island right
now or Fukushima we need to understand
that when you're looking at some of
these issues that they have with
Fukushima in particular which is a kind
of an antiquated system that they had
set up that they can't really shut off
which I had a whole bit about how crazy
that is
yeah but when you're talking about the
nuclear power that they could implement
today it would be a very different
system right there I'd be fairly clean
extremely high return on energy
investment yes and zero emissions yes
but there's a fear because of the past
just put it somewhere that sucks
yeah he's point out where that sucks put
a big one someone that sucks and juice
up the whole country with it you know
when it when it when it came to yang I
felt like here we had a guy who I'm not
a big fan of you bi and that's a weird
one right they I think the way he put it
spoke more to me than the way anyone
else ever framed it and I actually felt
like
he shouldn't have called it universal
basic income hmm when he didn't he call
it the freedom dividend right yeah but
it became ubi to so many people that's
the one with it yeah when you see you
know Amazon Google these big companies
becoming just insane behemoths they
can't you know they can't be broken up
they just absorb an absorb and absorb
there's an argument for some kind of
dividend to the American people for
potentially what they do outside of the
United States it's it's very complicated
up not economics I guess I'm not smart
enough to you know pretend like I know
anything about but you look at he
brought the example of Alaska they have
the oil drilling the people who live in
Alaska I get a portion of that revenue
and those profits that makes sense you
bi the way it's framed in general makes
very little sense and eventually I think
we're actually seeing now with the
government stimulus one of the biggest
pitfalls to it
do you hear there's a there was a story
they ran an NBC a woman her employees
were like in revolt because she acquired
a loan from the paycheck protection
program that insured their jobs meaning
they would receive less money because
under the cares Act they would have
received a bonus of $600 per week on top
of the salary they'd normally get they
actually preferred to have lost their
jobs so you have people who are
complaining that they're keeping their
jobs now so there's that's one instance
though there's a couple stories like
that but the challenge with just giving
people cash cash is the assumption that
the cash has inherent value when the
value of it is based upon what you can
get for it so one of the lessons I think
we learned now with the economy being
shut down is doctors and nurses got to
work you know that we need them on the
front line they're also getting paid
what do they use that money for pay
their rent buy food things like that
where I think we're facing food
shortages if you can't buy anything with
the money what's the point to taking the
money I mean like if you were given a
choice you're gonna work you're gonna go
work your job at a grocery store you're
an essential worker we're gonna pay for
in a bucks your buddy who is let me stop
you right there because the universal
basic income was not designed to deal
with the pandemic it was designed to
deal with automation which might have
not stopped the supply chain which has
not stopped which wouldn't have created
food shortages this is a sort of a
unique situation so you're comparing
apples oranges you're applying
Universal basic income to our current
situation which has nothing to do with
the reason why he wanted to implement it
in the first place he's worried that
automation is gonna take away jobs he's
right it will it probably not now
consider this problem though there will
always be some kind of essential work
right yes what you tell the essential
worker when other people are getting
money and don't work that you have no
choice because you're essential even in
an automation system so let's say every
job but great job but hold on a second
they're only getting a small amount of
money to stay alive you would rather
have a good job were you getting paid
well and have benefits and all that
other stuff
I think that's an assumption I see it is
an assumption but the basic income the
real problem there's a psychologist your
issue the real problem is the way human
beings work we need incentives we don't
yeah people don't just want to survive
and get a little check from the
government will be people be despondent
you know you you don't want to create
any united states of welfare like an
all-encompassing thing where some you
know these programs that are in place
that automate all of the goods and
services they take some of that money
and give it back to the people because
no one can work like that's a that's a
depressing dystopian future I mean
that's a terrible place to live
you ever watch Battlestar Galactica yes
loved ERC snowpiercer
what's that then you talk about the new
Battlestar Galactica one what was
snowpiercer which was out that's where
Chris Evans is on a train that travels
around the world because the world is
frozen and only that train has like it's
a kind of a weird premise but there's an
episode of but no no no no it's a movie
I'm just bringing up two different bits
of fiction to you know make a point
oh yeah it's a futuristic movie it's
real weird who else is in it Chris
captain Tilda Swinton right isn't it
yeah I think I did see that it's real
weird yeah it's kind of cool so they
take kids from the back from the poor
cart and have them work internally in
the engine because they have to move
things around because parts are missing
if they don't everyone all human life
dies so they literally go in the back
and they take children away from their
families who scream and reject this in
Battlestar they had children who were
also taken for a similar reason to work
you had people who had no choice but to
work on the fuel processing ship
otherwise all of you many we wiped out
one of often thought about you know I'm
a huge fan of starch at the next
generation how do we get to a post
capitalism world where we still have
incentives but we're post Reno
post-scarcity the problem is in it as
we're in transition there will be jobs
that are essential which means one of
the one of the glimpses we get I
understand a pandemic is different but
we still see a glimpse of people who
have to work you know kind of
low-skilled boring tedious jobs like a
grocery store while other people who
have higher skilled jobs are getting
their their needs met by the government
at least in terms of the cash so we're
we're here telling you know these people
talking about right now right right so I
understand it's a pandemic it's very
specific but we're getting a glimpse of
what happens when some people are told
your job is not essential so we're gonna
guarantee your food and resources for
the time being you are clearly doing
that though it's not just as effective
I'm just I'm just saying that as we move
towards automation there will still be
jobs that are essential what do we do
how do we you know incentivize and
compensate make that worth the people
who have no choice but to keep working
while the rest of us don't I don't know
if it's a keep working while the rest of
us don't issue I think it's a problem of
jobs being phased out I think the real
problem is automation is gonna phase out
jobs it's not gonna be about what's
essential what's not essential I think
you're sort of applying pandemic
vernacular to let's let's let's remove
the pandemic from it and let's say you
know right now one of the things I
looked at and we talked about this
little bit before I met a homeless guy
in Chicago and he worked at a job that
became obsolete I back build it yes I
asked a homeless guy how he became
homeless when I was when I was like 19
and he told me that he had a job he
worked there for 20 30 years as he got
older his family you know moved away
lost contact is there different times
some of friends and family had died when
his company became obsolete technology
didn't matter anymore he was cast out
you know he had nowhere to nowhere to
work anymore and his expertise was very
specific so he got a severance package
that ran out he got unemployment that
ran out he got kicked out now he's
homeless I look at that and I say how do
we make sure that doesn't happen this
guy should not be punished simply
because times have changed but if you
scale that up you know and say it keeps
happening in every different sector
eventually you'll end up with 90% of the
population saying my needs will be taken
and 10% saying I still have to work
whatever the industry may be like what
that's a transitional period is gonna be
very difficult we automate most jobs
that's up for some some people will
still have to work does anybody really
think you're gonna automate most jobs
though I mean there's so many jobs that
can't be motive automated yeah I don't
think that gotta be the I mean we're
you're talking about some weird sort of
futuristic version yeah I don't think
that's what we need to be concerned with
I think I think the idea of universal
basic income is wonderful the idea that
your your needs are taken care of in
terms of food and housing and then
everything else you got to do on your
own if if we're looking at when we look
at struggle right we look at struggle
like across the board can't feed
yourself can't put a roof over your head
can't do would have the this is what was
attractive about universal basic income
to me what if we all agreed that some
semblance of dignity is a part of being
an American and then we will provide you
with food we would provide you with
housing everything else you have to
[ __ ] earn and that's interesting
that's interesting I like that I like it
but I don't know
people don't work well when they don't
have to exactly when people don't have
an incentive and the competition is
important and when you look at people
that are anti-capitalist they're they're
really into socialism one of the things
you find is a lot of rich kids
it's weird right it's [ __ ] real weird
it's because they don't understand real
struggle because they've grown up
without it and they have these ideals
like they feel guilty because they've
grown up without struggle and they want
to help the world and they think
capitalism is evil and I never saw my
dad so we need to we need to get all
these rich people they need to give that
money to all these poor people when you
know balance out income you know what
else they notice the people around them
we're all white people that are into
socialism the the people that are in
socialism tend to be upper class upper
middle class obviously white
generalising in a big way right but
there there's there some studies some
research that came out and it finds the
overwhelming majority of socialists in
the United States yeah you know they
came from upper-middle class to upper
class families that tended to be white
yeah and so
that focused so hard and these social
justice warrior issues you you take a
person who's been surrounded by rich
white people yes it probably got a
reason to not like them but then they
assume all white people are the same and
you end up seeing this you know
racialization of politics also they find
themselves in a position of affluence
that they didn't earn they want to burn
it all the ground yep you know it's and
they assume you know I think there's
some truth in that you know that there's
people who have money they didn't earn
and there are leeches on the system they
make money from money they've never done
anything in their lives or their
arrogant sure there's a lot of people
like that right but you know when you
doesn't take that generalization and
apply it to anyone who has money or
everyone and you take it to a dark place
exactly when I when I first started you
know entering the public space in terms
of news and politics I was at Occupy
Wall Street and before I had any
notoriety I was being m''d they called
me a good example of what's wrong with
the system here's Tim Poole a high
school dropout mixed race guy and here
he is just sleeping in the dirt park
using his phone to tell the real stories
of the world after I got featured in
Time magazine what did they say
Tim Poole is white and he was born with
a silver spoon which is not true
is absolutely not true but the the the
socialist types the activists couldn't
accept that I had you know jumped the
the class system I guess their view of
the world is rigid that the rich people
keep the poor down there's no chance for
upward mobility and that's not the case
you know you absolutely can become
successful from you know humble me one
of my favorite AOC quotes was her
talking about it's literally impossible
to pull yourself up by your bootstraps
when she used to be a waitress
I know now she's a congresswoman like
she can't look it's not impossible but
it's not even that's what we need to
address it's not even the reality is
some people have a far easier path
absolutely some people have a far more
difficult path it's just these are this
is just but you have to deal with the
hand you're given if life is a game and
while I'm not saying it's a game it is
life but it's similar to a game in that
you're dealt a set of cards you're dealt
a set of circumstances and yes some
people just get four aces from birth
your dad's a multi billionaire and your
whole family's always been rich and you
never have to worry about a goddamn
thing for the rest of your life well
guess what those people
turn out to be [ __ ] miserable and
crazy there's some benefit in being born
with a shitty hand of cards absolutely
there really is a motivational benefit
for sure gumption yeah there's a TED
talk there's one one trait one
personality trait that guarantees
success of all it's not intelligence
it's not class not race not gender you
know what perseverance that's it there's
a TED talk on it it's it's it's
interesting and it's true now I think
there's there's always gonna be certain
limits based on your ability like I'm
never gonna play in the NBA right it's
all enough right nowhere near as fast I
can jump high enough actually that's not
true I can jump reai skateboard but you
take people who don't have top-tier
intelligence not the strongest but if
they work hard enough they can find
their their apex they can find that
point where they are successful and they
can make it right it's not true for
everybody some people are below that
that threshold no matter how hard they
try they're gonna need help well I think
the problem is with any sort of
generalization you know perseverance is
the most important thing yes sure but
you also have to be intelligent you
can't be doing the same thing over and
over again no I'm not gonna quit no you
have to be able to figure out what
you're doing wrong as well as have
perseverance perseverance is a necessary
part of the equation but there's many
pieces to that qualities but define
success in that regard right if success
is well it depends on the field that
you're choosing right if you're not
smart enough to be an astrophysicist you
shouldn't be an astrophysicist right
you're not tall enough to play in the
NBA you probably can't play min do you
think it's totally true though Mugsy
Bose that dude was amazing he was
amazing yeah it's 5 7 was he 16550 Webb
that's right Wow shorter than I thought
yeah yeah you can do it yeah that's
amazing it's very rare when we talk
about two guys right - exactly exactly
like that yeah I think the average
person has the potential and
capabilities of being successful wealthy
if they want famous I think one of the
challenges we have in our culture is how
we're raising kids and what we're in
what the values were giving them well
it's also what are you trying to do like
what do you just look there
thing hey there's a bunch of different
things that you could just you just
don't have like some people can't sing
they're not any [ __ ] talent I just
don't have it their voice sounds like
[ __ ] but guess who else's voice sound
like [ __ ] Bob Dylan terrible voice yeah
how does it feel man
people love it because there's like
authenticity and passion and there's
something to it right but he found out a
way to make it work you wouldn't win
American Idol [ __ ] no imagine this music
one of the greatest musicians are
feeling
imagine him going like someone saying
what do you want to do man I want to be
a singer songwriter okay just without
any music what only interesting me a
song probably probably well you know
there's there there are a lot of people
especially in the internet day and age
that you would not expect to have made
it who made it yes no that's you know
there's a lot yeah I mean that's and
then there's rules today that I don't
think really hold true you know people
say oh you know you have to be
good-looking you have to be thin well
Adele's not thin she is now she's thin
now people are mad at her for being thin
yeah she just was talented she said a
powerful voice or that woman Susan what
it was her name that was on America's
Got Talent
I don't know no but it wasn't America's
Got Talent an x-factor x-factor right
isn't boil that [ __ ] wizard over here
Susan Boyle she looked like someone's
Grammy right and but she belted out this
song that made Simon Cowell almost cry
Wow because she's just [ __ ] talented
just really good you can find a thing
but you know if you're Susan Boyle and
you want to be a comedian
maybe her jokes are [ __ ] terrible
maybe she would show up at open mic
night it's a Sunday night at the Comedy
Store over and over again and keep
bombing and then you know she never
would have made it yeah I can't learn
some people it I think I think if you
can if you can learn right if you can
you know what one of the problems those
people refuse to accept when they're
wrong they rise see self-critical yeah
they're not they don't have an
analytical perspective in terms of their
own issues
they can't analyze themselves and see
the flaws and be objective and
introspective some people just don't
have that because they've been
protecting themselves they they have
these sort of personality traits that
protect themselves from self deprecation
from
understanding where their flawed when I
was a teenager I remember reading that
Michael Jordan would watch tapes of
himself playing I figure I would get
wrong I know that's true but to me that
was like if you want to be the best like
Em's you need to actively look for what
you're screwing up yeah call out
immediately
well that's imperative for sparring yeah
when you're sparring like we used to
film a lot of back when I was competing
we'd film sparring sessions and fights
particular fights but sparring sessions
it was critical because you could see
how you were telegraphing something and
then you got countered you could see how
and sometimes you don't ya think you're
doing it then you realize that oh my god
I'm dropping my hand every time I do
this and then you get caught Razia
yeah it's like that's with everything
they're like poker yeah yeah giving your
nails away mm-hmm it's not but I think
most things you'd be better off seeing
like with comedy its massive it's
gigantic being able to visually see
yourself is like primary that's number
one a little bit little bit less good is
listening to yourself and at a certain
point in time in your career you can get
away with just listening in terms of
like but there's a big difference
between people who monitor their stuff
and go over it and analyze it versus
people who don't it's just it's it's
accelerated learning it's like taking
advantage of all the tools that you're
given and you can apply that to anything
that you're trying to do good in life if
you have the time and the energy if
you're doing a job and during this job
you know you just show up at work and
you try to do your best then you go home
you [ __ ] off and you do your stuff
you'll get better at whatever you do
exactly but if you go and do your job
and then afterwards analyze what you did
pay attention to it write things down
make a diary perhaps or review your work
and really you'll get better faster it's
a matter of how much time as long as you
don't burn out I don't take days off
ever yeah that's weird
I took a day off yesterday had some bad
sushi I here's a lesson everybody if if
I don't want to be mean to the sushi
people they're really nice to me but you
know maybe maybe lay off sushi if
they've been close for a month
and well you're driving from the other
side of the country text men I'll tell
you the place there's only I go to like
four places out here for sushi and
everywhere else I'm like you know well
so here's what I wanted to say right I
don't take a day off and a lot of people
say I'm crazy
and I've actually in my Monday through
Friday is now double shifts every day
then Saturday and Sunday are single
shifts in terms of production so I do
Monday through Friday 3 hours and 40
minutes about Saturday and Sundays about
an hour and 40 minutes and and what
would I do if I wasn't working I'll be
playing video games but listen to the
numbers you just said yeah three hours
and forty Monday through Friday yeah and
then an hour and a half per weekend day
yeah that's still not a full day's work
so an hour and a half of recording is
like ten hours of research oh okay well
so it's like eight out so I'm doing
constant research in between
fact-checking and then I work like once
I get everything in line and I think I'm
confident on what I'm what you know what
I have and of course I'm right I'm not
perfect then I record for about 20
minutes then I get back to researching
reading and I you know so it's it's
there's another benefit though you work
for yourself absolutely you don't have
some [ __ ] over your shoulder telling
you what to do I chose this though right
so so there's a couple things when you
brought up you'll get good at whatever
use whatever as you do I tell my friends
every second you spend doing something
as an investment to be into being better
than better at that so if you want to
come home from work and play video games
all day you'll be really good at video
games man um maybe you start a stream be
a twitch channel maybe maybe you can
make you know some money being a good
personality but you got to earn it or
maybe there's something you want to do
that instead of playing video games you
do that instead for me when I'm not
working I'm just sitting around like why
am I not working what like what am i
doing
you know I'm it's I ended up taking
yesterday off I didn't work today
because we're doing the show and so I'm
sitting you know sitting around watching
TV shows like this is awful I can't
stand I gotta read the news man I got it
I gotta be in I got to be into it
well you're driven but also you're
enjoying it that's the difference
between someone who's working and
[ __ ] coal mine or someone who's
working in a field all day picking
strawberries yeah but I hate the job
yeah I hear you but you know you know
many people have hit me up you probably
something similar like how do I do what
you do you know when I was working for
vice and I was travel around the world
ten 20 emails every week from young
people saying I really want to do what
you do and you know what you know with
what they would say to me when I would
tell them how to do it they would say I
would never do that
I I would tell them here's what you do
do you have any money saved up no okay
where do you work
you don't work get a job Starbucks
McDonald's whatever you can get maybe
you can do better than that
save your money once you've saved enough
find a store you want
fly there cover it you know they would
say no I had one there's one person who
that said to me I want to travel around
the world and do what you do how do I do
it I say do you have money saved up yes
excellent there's a story right now
going on in Turkey all right you got to
be secure you got to be safe but it
symbols fairly okay fly there right now
film it and you know I'll see if I can
make any connections on what you find
and yet they said well the money I saved
it from my apartment in Brooklyn and I'm
like right what's more important to you
having your nice Williamsburg apartment
or being a journalist traveling around
the world well I like my apartment I'm
like okay listen when I worked for Vice
I was sleeping on a couch every time
they paid me I put in the bank I didn't
touch it I got a job working for a
Disney and ABC News joint venture
company after that they paid me a bunch
of money I put 70% the bank I didn't
touch it when I left I went to a bunch
of these New York digital companies you
know I'll spare them their names for any
embarrassment many of them who have
become rather worthless this will exist
in their bag and I decided after seeing
what they had to offer the bias the
deception the the clickbait driven
nature of it I'm doing myself and
because I saved my money every step of
the way I was able to do so so then I
had an apartment then I could pay for my
plane ticket you know to Sweden to
France to Germany to do these stories
and started building up a base within
about seven or eight months I had gone
from red to black so now all of a sudden
I was no longer losing money I was
making money and I'm like there it is
couple of years on ridiculous it's
ridiculous is ridiculously successful
for myself I guess I could you know it's
relative but I've got some several
employees launching new companies well
one of the companies shattered a
fundraising record of a million bucks in
a single day so that's that that's look
the path through me isn't the path of
everybody but sacrifice you know well
you're basically saying exactly what
they're saying in TED talk perseverance
but and you you embrace the grind but
it's also what do you really prioritize
yeah for me what are you trying to do I
don't care about having an apartment I
want to I want to I want to see what was
going on the ground in Istanbul so you
know what it's also like who who is the
type of person that would chase down the
stories the type of person that's really
gonna chase down the stories the
person's is driven to chase down stories
what you're getting is questions from
idiots you're getting questions from
people too like how do I do it and then
when you offer the answer I'm not gonna
do that
right those are the people that are
never gonna make it but the conversation
I have with Ari Shaffir where he and
Robert Kelly apparently they thought
about sponsoring a comic who's
up-and-coming taking care of their
financial needs and you know for like a
year and a lot trying to see how far
they could get in their career if they
didn't have to deal with money and I
said that's the problem is the type of
person who's going to make it is going
to make it not just in spite of the fact
that they don't have any money but
because of the fact they don't have any
money
heroes day jobs those sucky jobs that
you need to have when you're struggling
those they [ __ ] motivate you they're
important if somebody just comes along
gives you all the money you need for
food you're gonna have asset and some
hungry guy in the other side of town is
gonna take all the gigs that you would
get they're gonna write better jokes
they're gonna be more motivated to go to
open mics they're gonna pound the
pavement harder well I got a story for
you
I'll try get details right so my buddy's
company so forgive me if I'm if I'm
getting details wrong but he had a
social media management company he
started himself he knew everything about
social media Instagram and all that and
he started building up a client base
where I'm gonna run your social media
for you worked like a charm so I'm
making ton of money getting new
contracts these companies and what they
were doing he got to a point where to
hire people
he ended up hiring a couple college
grads and he put up the ad saying you
know college degree required they
couldn't figure anything out they kept
calling them having problems couldn't
manage anything so he fires him rehires
again more college grads same problem
eventually has to fire him then he hires
because he's running out of money he
hires to high school I think they're
high school dropouts and he was like
they wanted substantially less money and
at this point I just couldn't find good
people they worked swimmingly it was
amazing no phone calls no problems
these were people who had worked hard
saved up money in their small bumpkin
hometown moved to Los Angeles to make it
big they knew what they wanted they knew
what they had to do and they said I will
find a way to do it he said the other
people are hiring were just like drones
they just wanted a job they didn't know
or care what they were doing they didn't
bother so they don't wanna learn but
these people who were driven viewed this
as just another problem to be solved on
my path to success yeah that's that's
the mindset and that's the difference
the mindset of success is the mindset of
I will figure it out so I think the
problem is how we're raising people in
this country we're raising them too
in certain areas to expect things to be
given to you you get a participation
trophy no matter what you do your
congratulations this is the problem with
socialism and this is the problem with
universal basic income what we're
talking about yeah yeah expecting
something from the government
particularly without any financial
feasibility there's no there's no real
logic to where that money comes from
like show me where work is right right
what is money you know so so one of the
arguments I keep seeing from a lot of
people who have more I don't want to
calm socialist I think they're just
regular urban dwelling like liberal left
type people mmm there's one viral post
on on ret on Reddit that said you've got
these conservatives or you've got these
people out protesting so they can enrich
their landlords and these billionaires
when they should be demanding that rent
be waived that mortgages you know in
evictions be cancelled and that the
government take care of their needs and
provide them with stimulus or something
like that and and and I look at that
like you're very clearly living in a
city but what they don't understand is
they say things like you know landlord
isn't a job like I argue that there's a
lot of very successful landlords who
make a ton of money and do very little
but it's a [ __ ] job right it's not
just that it's the money you pay in rent
can't just be wiped out because there's
groundskeepers there's maintenance
there's administrative assistance
there's taxes that be filed rent doesn't
just go into their pocket so they can
buy a boat but they view it this way and
they think that money is is what you
want that when they say these people who
want the government to be reopened you
know are simply trying to enrich the
wealthy it's like I think maybe they
make things and they want to keep making
things they want they want their economy
not the government the economy
yeah mixing that up but there's there
they're there a lot of people that don't
seem to understand I think it's because
when you live in a city everything's
already there for you when I lived in
New York the Williamsburg Bridge boom
there it is I didn't see it built I
didn't pay a dime for it and I can just
use it I can cross over it's just there
and I've never had to you know you never
had to fight for it so you just say why
can't I just have it you see you walk in
any store and there's food hey there's
food easy what they don't see is the
supply chain where the food is made the
work that goes into it so they assume
that money guarantees access to it which
it doesn't if the economy is shut down
the money can't buy you things the value
of that money starts going down if the
farms can't sell any of this to anybody
and start dumping and I think it's
called fallowing fields no longer
farming then there's nothing to buy
so if products aren't being made and
services aren't being rendered because
the economy is closed
what is your money gonna get you at a
certain point when the economy has shut
down for too long and we're seeing all
of these businesses closed family
businesses I heard a story terrible
tragedy
somebody killed himself because there's
their family business of seven years was
shut down that net product is gone so
eventually there's no food to buy and
only then will people realize that the
government stimulus money has no
inherent value it's it's the work we do
for each other that's the argument being
left out when you when you get a biased
view on social media or when these
people don't quite understand you know
that's the problem there's a lot of
noise people that don't quite understand
people that aren't a part of the supply
chain that really don't know what it's
like to like the people that raise food
they're freaking out right now yeah
people that raise cattle and the people
that grow food and the fact that they
have to deal with being shut down and
trying to figure out how to restart
things and when is it gonna be okay to
restart things well and what if it
happens again with there's another
flare-up two months from now I mean
they're hurting right now and they might
might take years to recover from these
past couple months well there was I
think some health official in California
saying they might not not not be able to
fully reopen until as a vaccine which
could take 18 months fully reopened what
like to go back to normal right so I
think there was an MIT Technology Review
article talking about how we may have to
do intermittent lockdowns
you know like two months lock down one
month off
until the vaccine is available then
there was another another study came out
saying something similar about herd
immunity
I mean Sweden they think they're there
on target for the end of May that herd
immunity which is like 60 percent I
think yeah I the information keeps
changing you know we're learning more so
maybe these statements are at this point
I don't know obsolete yeah Sweden's a
weird place to because it's a it
consists mostly of little villages why
Sweden yes big cities well you have
Stockholm but the primarily the
population is sort of its it's separated
by these smaller towns it's not you're
right over there
I see you've already been tested for the
co vid I'm really worried about you
right now people are weird about coughs
now no I inhaled water yeah coughs are
nerve-racking for folks oh that's brutal
all right yeah you gave me this bottle
of water and I hailed it don't think you
just messed me up are you okay yeah
think so give me it yeah relax no it's
okay I got Joe gave me the test three no
no kovat nineteen yeah your your voice
sounds terrible right now I just inhaled
water how did you inhale it I don't know
I was trying to drink it and I nailed it
bad happens now I sound weird right yeah
you saw a different person the
luminosity critism you with somebody
else yeah you're too controversial
well that [ __ ] you were saying to people
up all right think I'm better i won't i
won't inhale the water that's it feels
weird um Kyle Cohen school me something
today I wanted you to see Jamie it's
some thing there's some [ __ ] going down
with UFO sightings oh yeah yeah before
well yeah but they were new here I'll
send it I'll send it to you I've been
following this stuff yeah it's um hold
on a second Jamie all right I just
texted it to you Pentagon officially
releases UFO this is the tweet it says
new Pentagon formally released three
mysterious UFO videos captured by Navy
pilots the already leaked video
showed what DoD insist on calling
unidentified aerial phenomena moving at
incredible speeds and performing near
impossible maneuvers this is a weird
subject because it's one of those
subjects where people automatically
dismiss it because it's been it's been
so touted by kook's there's so many
wacky [ __ ] that have talked about UFOs
that anybody talking about UFOs has to
be out of their [ __ ] mind but then
when you see these videos and you see
them performing these impossible tasks
like these things are moving in a way
that we've never seen anything move
before flipping upside down and sideways
moving and insane rates of speed like
they don't know what these are
yeah you know phenomena what's
interesting though is I was reading one
of these stories and they passively
mentioned that the sighting was near a
technology and a u.s. naval like
technology station of some sort mmm like
a top-secret development and I'm like
that could be one of two things either
right it's developed by the people that
are at that base or they're monitoring
the people that are at that base these
aircraft we call them aircraft are
displaying characteristics that are not
currently within the u.s. inventory nor
any foreign inventory that we are aware
of maybe they see this [ __ ] that's going
down with China and all the ships being
moved and like listen you [ __ ] the
aliens yeah listen you [ __ ] [ __ ]
territorial Apes I'd like to think that
but you don't think so Manhattan Project
man I mean the US has probably got some
crazy [ __ ] weapons it could be
but the Manhattan Project was also
coincidentally right after they started
detonating bombs and the aliens start
showing up that's what they think right
yeah well that was when the the bulk of
US sightings started jumping and
worldwide I believe too you know
maybe we've slowly been getting more and
more information about this I've been
actually reading a lot of these stories
of the past several months more
admissions from government more release
of documents and more sightings so
there's been a big I don't want to call
it well a lot of people murmuring that
April was gonna be the month when we
finally learned the truth April's almost
up it's almost
almost that we gotta wait a few days man
twenty-seventh you know what I use more
days is left do you know 13:30 you know
about happened the you know about the
O'Hare Airport sighting which ones that
so this was I think in like oh six at
Chicago's International O'Hare a UFO
came down and hovered above I think I
camera which eternal terminal it was
hovered for a few minutes I think and
then shot straight punched a hole in the
clouds everybody saw it happen
now I had just quit working at O'Hare
around this time when the sighting
happened so I had friends who were still
there
I had a friend tell me that when this
UFO came down people on Mannheim Road
where which is the road on the side of
O'Hare got out of their cars like just
stopped the light got up and we're
looking and staring at it and that the
people who are working where we worked
we worked for American Eagle Airlines
walked out of the rooms and we're just
staring at it float and then shoot up
and punch a hole in the clouds you know
they said weather phenomenon so there's
a photo of it a pilot took a photo of it
this is back when like very early phone
cameras that's a very grainy awful
picture there that's that's not it no no
that's super fake all right I think no
these are all people trying to fake it's
really hard to find that one is not that
one might be it but I don't think so it
it barely looks like cargo O'Hare UFO
sighting 2006 said it right there I do
not believe those are it no so this will
click on that article see what it says
Jamie that one might be on the left but
so many people try exploiting this stuff
for for clicks and fervor views and they
make these fake photos and it was links
not working it was a very very faint
photo from the from the cockpit it might
be that one right there in the middle no
no so on the left side for well it might
be that one no no it's not it that's not
it
well there was a really crappy photo of
it and that might be that might be it
was a really it was out of the cockpit
of a window a pilot took a photo and you
know I wonder where of all the sightings
gone since phones became ubiquitous I
mean this is a simple you know I guess
excuse the aliens they're sentient they
know we have phones they're like okay
stop
you know decloaking or whatever but I
want or I wonder if you know why is it
there were so many UFOs and then around
the time cellphone cameras come out
they're gone well I think most people
are full of [ __ ] yeah yeah I think most
people like to pretend they see things
that don't really see things but you
know I don't think that excludes the
possibility it's not like it's it's not
like it's these things are mutually
exclusive like people are full of [ __ ]
therefore aliens don't exist I think
aliens could be real and people are full
of [ __ ] and I think that it could be
it's very rare that they visit us but if
they did like well how often do
scientists go to the Congo to study
chimps I mean how many people do they
send let me let me the bottom of the
ocean to look for new life-forms how
rare is it
let me trip you out okay on that idea we
put decoys up for animals animals can't
tell the difference what if you've
actually met a decoy person you couldn't
tell the difference maybe it's you bro
maybe it's me
that's right unless we're able to work
so much oh yeah robot I don't get tired
no so you're interested in news and
disseminating factual evidence because
we're actually doing is collecting a
database for the for the aliens no but I
thought about this because I saw a photo
on Reddit of puffins I think it's called
the bird and they put up a fake puffins
and it's because I think they're called
puffins it's because the birds don't
like you know nesting in places where
they're alone and so I putting the decoy
there the other birds would start coming
and like one bird showed up and was
hanging out with the decoy and I'm like
could you imagine like you see like you
we put duck decoys in the water we do
duck calls and the Ducks like oh wait
fly honey I'm gonna come over and check
this out and it's like a wood block
could you imagine like seeing like a
beautiful woman or someone you're
attracted to and being like look at that
it's really like an alien decoy just to
like probe you and like better
understand you or something well the
decoy just the term decoys weird because
decoys are used for hunting like turkeys
turkey season right now yeah and the way
that hunt most guys hunt for turkeys
they take a rubber turkey you put that
[ __ ] out in the middle of the field
and then you hide behind a bush with a
shotgun and then that turkeys like hear
it and they come over and they try to
get some [ __ ]
and then they get shot so what if you
know you see some dude and or it's like
you see it for you
you know beautiful woman you won't get
that [ __ ] you know and then she's going
like hey hey come over here and you're
like oh hey me and then I get eaten no
no they just you know take up in the
ship Probie on a MicroBot need to this
is the thing about putting things up
your butt most doctors don't even do
that like they have MRIs now tenant
aliens need to probe you in your ass I
think it's just what everyone's afraid
of they're afraid of things go in their
ass so that's what they they think is
gonna happen if the aliens get them a
little fries me somebody somebody told
the dumb story back in the day and it
was the most sensational version
everybody had to have it so they were
like that's what they went with you know
maybe or maybe they do that to keep you
to keep your mouth shut
they [ __ ] you in the ass just so you
keep your mouth shut or some dude
actually got abducted right yeah
and he comes back and he's like they
think they won against me they think
they beat me they puts up with my butt
they're weirdos do you hear the story of
Betty and Barney Hill now it's the very
first UFO abduction story it's an
ancient story and what's crazy is Angela
Hill who's a UFC fighter I had her on
the podcast and after the show she told
me her grandpa was Barney Hill whoa and
I was like holy [ __ ] like we forgot to
we didn't talk about it during the show
but she wanted to bring it up because
she knows I'm kind of obsessed with UFOs
but the account that they have like they
get hypnotized and he's recalling the
abduction and they have like the same
story it's very terrifying they hear him
crying and screaming and you know that
he was taken aboard this craft and
examined and brought back and they have
missing time but here's the thing if
they only did that occasionally they
only came down once every few years and
just scoop some person up in the middle
of some rural place like if you're
flying over you know I think their
instance was in I believe it was in
Maine if you're flying over somewhere
like Maine which is a very low
population state and you see a lone car
and it's just traveling along the
highway and there's places in Maine
where you go from like Portland to
Bangor when you're traveling on that
road it's like 60 miles with nothing not
a gas station nothing if you were an
alien you saw a car by itself like no
other car will move in we got one
isn't it just easier to think it's the
US government no why not because we
don't have the capability of doing
something like that
think I don't think the capability of
the scientists working for the
government is any different than the
capability of the science scientists
that are working for you know Project X
or you know fill in the blanks in terms
of like what Raytheon publicly traded
companies how long look yet quadcopters
don't seem all that complicated to me
quadcopters yeah like a helicopter like
you drums you know we've seen a little
toys you buy they got four propellers
take take that concept use thinner you
know jets and surround it in a disc so
that it's you know universally like it
can move in any direction because it's
gotten you know source where's the gas
tank
well lithium-ion battery or come on
you're talking space [ __ ] like this
hasn't even been invented yet think
about how little mileage you can get out
of a Tesla
you know they had advances Tesla's you
know still when it's going full out it
can only go for I mean you get three
hundred seven miles if you drive like a
grandma but if you drive like a maniac
you don't even you'd have that you know
that they could be wrong with this but
I'm pretty sure that they had this
flying platform in the 70s that uses gas
power and they've also had jetpacks for
a long time know they've had sort of
they've had jet packs that are capable
of going for like thirty seconds they
don't exactly know no I'm pretty sure
the jet packs back in the day went for a
long no no they definitely didn't we can
lay it out yeah let's look it up because
I didn't the whole thing was the fact
they were burning gas and to propel you
in the air they only had a certain
amount I thought it was like 20 minutes
20-30 minutes maybe now my understanding
of why we abandoned jetpack technology
was that it was inefficient and heavy
and you couldn't carry it without it
being turned on so they opted for larger
like you know like what are they called
Chinook's helicopters that can carry
multiple people multiple people at once
when you're wearing a jet pack it has to
be on idle
negating its own weight which means it's
burning as you're walking around which
means you get a good 20-minute jump and
you gotta abandon the tech and then you
don't want your enemies to get it have
you ever seen a guy flyer jet pack yeah
as a video on youtube no I mean in real
life oh I've seen that one guy the Iron
Man dude what real life in there and
really my friend Willie be from in
Denver on the radio yeah
had a radio show in the morning h2s
radio show he still has a radio show
shout out to Willie and he had this guy
who was a jet pack pilot who came in and
in the parking lot of the radio studio
and you know fans of the radio show came
and did it too and watched it rather and
this guy flew in the air for about 15-20
seconds and then landed this guy was so
banged up he both of his legs were blown
apart he had he had big braces on both
of his knees I'm like what happened your
knees he's like just crash landing both
knees are blown to [ __ ] hit no ACLs and
either one of his knees but what I'm
saying like this is back then right good
for about 30 seconds 10 seconds of
flying well so the point I'm trying to
get to is if you take something like a
quadcopter you could absolutely feel it
with with you know gasps loud as [ __ ] it
but it would it would depending on how
you measure engine to be an engine yeah
it'd be loud as [ __ ] and you'd hear from
the from the quadrotor yeah but these
what these people are describing is
nothing like that these people are
describing things that are silent that
go from zero to a thousand miles an hour
in a split second the things that defy
physics as we understand them this is
not something that I think that the u.s.
government has I don't I just if you
look at like okay like Elon Musk company
project X or SpaceX SpaceX is right now
one of the premier civilian companies
private companies that's making rocket
ships they [ __ ] up all the time total
there in the middle of innovating all
the time he's one of the smartest people
on earth he's one of the in terms of
Technology he's one he knows as much
about propulsion as anyone and they
still can't get it right they're still
trying to figure it out they're trying
to come up with something that could be
viable in terms of commercial space
flight and they're working on it daily
and these these people are the brightest
minds we know of right now they're in
this jet propulsion space travel
business there's you know virgins
working on something as a couple other
companies that are working on things as
well and then you have NASA which worked
they're the best they could come up with
was the Space Shuttle right do you think
that there was something way better than
Space Shuttle they just met
we used that they had and they they kept
it on the back burner didn't want to let
anybody know but the way they would use
it is they would pick people up and
erase their memory and exhort their
[ __ ] that's crazy well that's less
likely than the hundreds of billions of
galaxies just in our own in our own
known universe right each one with
hundreds of billions of stars each star
with who knows how many [ __ ] planets
that's somewhere out there there's
something more advanced than us maybe a
thousand years maybe a million years but
that it's figured out how to come here I
got same question then why hasn't why
isn't anyone discovered them
why is SETI failed search search for
extraterrestrial intelligence why
haven't the chimps invented guns
they've started using more tools but
right why haven't they invented guns
though I don't know so why hasn't said
he found UFOs the same [ __ ] answer
they're not advanced enough yet really
it's a it's a real simple answer the
Industrial Age is a pretty [ __ ]
recent right I mean you think about when
people invented cars you're talking
about 1800 that's really recent and we
call these lights 1800s like high power
radio transmission is only in the past
100 years or so right well you saw it
you've seen the movie contact maybe
that's the old one right it's Jodie
Foster and Matthew McConaughey it's a
based on Carl Sagan's book about contact
with space and with with aliens I think
I did see it recently I can interesting
interesting take on it but oh yeah way
is that they've received the signal that
we sent out way way back you know in the
day actually when the the first
broadcast signal was Hitler announcing
the Olympic Games to start of the Berlin
games and this was the first signal they
got there's a really controversial
moment in the movie or controversy it
you know in the plot with that once they
were trying to decipher the image that
was being sent they realize it was
Hitler yeah
the first thing they see is a swastika
what the [ __ ] is this send it back to us
and then they had to realize oh no no
this is the first image that we sent out
to space they wouldn't be able to
understand the political or historical
context of this and well so so I got a
few there's a few issues I see in terms
of aliens and earth contact right
we are substantially more connected
you know in an evolutionary chain - ants
than we are to any alien so we we can't
communicate with them for the most part
we kind of can we understand how they
communicate but when an ant sees a
superhighway there's something like this
is someone else's quote they don't think
twice
so it's possible there are aliens that
have super highways right above us we
can't tell what it is same as a dog
doesn't understand other than state
government but one of the one of the
issues I think is often neglected in the
conversation about aliens is the we
assume aliens would be on a very similar
planet to us we assume that they would
have some kind of gaseous atmosphere
perhaps it's a liquid atmosphere and one
of the things that I would ask of a
researchers I'm not the expert is the
fact that we have the proper balance of
oxygen the atmosphere to manipulate fire
which allows us to you know separate
elements and then create computers and
components and fuels wouldn't exist on a
planet without the same you know
atmosphere we existed to stop I can
answer that really easy yeah
there's no known propulsion system for
any of these crafts these things are not
using fire they don't have a heat signal
there they don't know what they are they
don't know how that works I don't mean
propulsion I mean the separation of
elements the manipulation of elements
right so we we melt things and separate
them and break them down they don't
believe that that's how it works no but
I mean like how do you even start from
I'm sure there's an answer you know
let's say you have you have a species
that lives on a planet with no oxygen it
has no access to fire what energy like
what dense energy source do they have
that will allow them to manipulate
matter do you know the Rob Lazar the bob
lazar story I do yeah well one of the
things that he talked about when he
first stopped working for area s4 and
the government was tapping his phones
and you know there's there's a lot that
can be documented about him there's a
lot that can't be but one of the things
that he talked about was a thing called
element 115 right that element 115 this
is insanely dense element that they use
to bend gravity and that the way he
described the way the propulsion system
works it's like putting a bowling ball
in the center of a very soft mattress
and that all of the other mattress all
the rest of the mess the mattress bends
around the intense mass of the bowling
ball and that this is how these
incredibly advanced aliens from this
other planet use
this is their propulsion system that was
used from Star Trek though the the
concept of warp was all around for a
really long I think the concept is based
on Einstein's theory of gravity I mean
this is the whole idea if you could find
something that could do that but here's
the thing
when Bob Lazar talked about this in the
late 80s early 90s this element didn't
exist right now it does it wasn't it
wasn't proven until they did it in a
particle collider I believe it was 2013
so he was talking about this element far
before it was it was and he's apparently
this is the big rumor he apparently had
taken some of that from a lab yeah and
through George Noory and it was a George
Noory yes they did some experiments on
the on television and showed that this
stuff had made light and fog bend in a
way that they couldn't describe he also
didn't he also claimed to see a small
alien creature on his way out he said he
saw something that was sitting down but
he doesn't know if it was a model that
they were using like if they had created
something that was supposed to be the
size of a thing that could fit in these
crafts because these crafts he said
we're designed for things that were far
smaller than human beings I'm pretty
sure in the initial interview he gave
when he went public was that he saw an
alien and then later on changed it
saying I don't know if it was maybe a
model or a puppet yeah he said he
thought he saw something sitting down
and two people standing over it looking
at it he said he thought he saw an alien
you know but he's probably I mean I
don't know I mean look he said it was
literally for like a half a second look
it's walking by a window and he sees
something inside of it imagine being a
guy who's in your 20s and you're a
propulsions expert and it's been proved
and he worked at Los Alamos labs has
been proven that he did put a [ __ ]
jet engine yeah it's been proven that he
did put a jet engine on a Honda I mean
he's a genius he's a and then you talk
to him he's an incredibly smart guy now
imagine you get sent off to area s4 and
they show you this thing that you know
doesn't even exist and they tell you
about this propulsion method that they
don't understand and they say that they
found this a long time ago in an
archeological dig and they want you to
back engineer it because you're a
propulsion
expert and they're running out of
options they've been studying this for
decades no one knows what the [ __ ] it is
or how you can make it work and then
they do test flights with this thing and
then he tells his friends about these
test flights after he gets [ __ ] you
know I got fired do you know a story
about him getting fired he leaked it or
something no no his wife is [ __ ] her
flight instructor oh and so when his
wife was [ __ ] her flight instructor
they told him he couldn't work anymore
and he's like why not well they were
tapping his phone because when you have
top-secret clearance to work on UFOs I
guess they don't want your fight your
your wife [ __ ] her flight instructor
then you're gonna go crazy and you have
a lot of imbalance at home right so he
doesn't know why they don't tell him why
so he takes his friends and he tells
them listen this is this is real they're
running these experiments I know you
think I'm crazy this is what I've been
working on so he takes them to this area
where you used to be able to have access
to but once he did this they closed off
access and pushed it far back to where
the public has access to and he showed
them these things doing these impossible
maneuvers in the desert in the night sky
as I remember and so then he gets
arrested and so when he gets arrested he
was a fear he was in fear of his own
life he goes public and tells this whole
story and then they erase his past they
erased his social security number they
erase his education background even
though people that knew him and knew he
worked at Los Alamos labs
he takes George Noory of a tour of Los
Alamos labs knows the people that worked
there they all say hi to him he takes
them a tour around the laboratory yeah
shows them around shows them the the
devices they use for biometric security
and I think the one thing you can't
ignore is that he'd he'd there was there
was documentation that he did work in
one of these places yes and they later
claimed he didn't yes and like I think I
was watching the thing on maybe was
Netflix I think like he promoted that
right it was undone yeah that's what's
they show the paper like we found yes
like he clearly was there he was in the
employee right yeah no but but you know
for me you know man I'd love to believe
it all he's been insanely consistent
about that story yeah for 40 years I I
want to believe you know 30 years
whatever yeah I want to believe - that's
the problem man paper didn't I want to
believe but that's nonsense pics or it
didn't happen is
cents well I'm not how do you how do you
you know how do you what about
Neanderthals none what about dinosaurs
there's not mix I'm more so joking right
what I mean it's tell me the evidence
right I get it
let's you know the challenge with any
theory I like I don't like saying
conspiracy theory because they're not
always conspiracies is that people want
something to be true and so they end up
looking for things to justify what they
think it already is of course instead of
starting with what you've got trying to
figure out where it goes from there but
when you start with what you've got
you've got a guy who was living in Vegas
was taking these flights out to area s4
knows the place knows it inside out can
describe it very accurately also worked
at Los Alamos labs that very accurately
yeah it proves he worked there yeah but
I cruise easily he's also a legitimate
scientist but what I mean when you talk
to the guy he's a brilliant guy but he's
not a nut right what are you saying
aliens that doesn't mean aliens no I'm
just asking like so it doesn't mean
aliens but that's what he was told
right what he was told is this is
something that has come from somewhere
else and they're trying to figure out
how to work it how do you what if we're
in a simulation and this was something
that was leftover code or it you know
wasn't supposed to be placed in this
curtain iteration would if there's
multiple dimensions that we don't have
access to and that these things do you
know my favorite I want to call it
conspiracy theory but might one of my
favorite stories is humanity emerged on
Venus and that we destroyed the planet
with a greenhouse effect so we created
the ark project and took the DNA of two
of every animal and loaded up on us on
the last vessel the ark and went to
terraform earth and that's the dumbest
idea ever it's hilarious DNA of two of
each animal and then how many copies of
those things do you make before they eat
each other they got they got they got
graphtec they they they just started
seeding the planet and what people do
I'm again I'm not saying it's I think
it's a fun story they argue that the
Bible was like the stories being told
and retranslated over hundreds of years
to a lost civilization that had only one
ship escaped the destruction of their
planet and I'm not saying it's true I'm
saying it's a fun story I love that
story yeah it's fun it would be a fun
sci-fi movie and then you end up with
lost tech being discovered well yeah
here's like Elon let's say we have to
get off
you know there's so many people that say
we have to escape earth we have to we
have to sort of colonize the solar
system or colonize the galaxy I agree
and I think if we don't discover a
better propulsion than hard chemical
energy we're not going to do it so yeah
well that's why this is so compelling
this idea that they're using some
element that apparently is impossible to
find here you can only create it with a
particle collider but maybe in whatever
solar system they are coming from you
have a very different environment and
maybe this element was the primary
source for fuel they might have figured
that out a long time ago I wonder if I'd
love to talk to an actual physicist
about this is there something with
negative density what's that mean so
like you know things with density create
an attraction through gravity because
they the the pressure that like their
their influence on space-time I'm not an
astrophysicist so I can't explain it to
you perfectly but you know the larger
that more dense the object the more pull
it has you know so I could very dense
black hole for instance sucks you in
then you know Mars has silenced gravity
than us cuts less dense
I wonder if there's something again this
probably you know I'm sure there's some
scientists laughing right now what a
[ __ ] but negative density something
that would actually have a real effect
in terms of gravity in which case you
could have some kind of object with
where you can control expand and
contract density so that you're pushing
and pulling
I don't know but Bob lazarre's
perspective is if we showed a nuclear
reactor to a civilization from the 1400s
they would think we're doing witchcraft
the Ark of the Covenant yeah they would
think it is absolutely the craziest
thing that anyone has ever seen or heard
they would try to tamper with it they'd
all get radiation poisoning and die
they'd never be able to figure it out in
the million years if you just left it
with them if you left some sort of a
nuclear reactor with them and he said
this is really how far advanced he
believes these these aliens or whatever
you want to call them are that they're
their science their technology is
indistinguishable from magic because
they're so far ahead of us do you think
they'd want to be involved with us
beyond us why wouldn't you we study
butterflies we study mice we study we
study bugs and the other side of the
planet we send
people unscientific journeys to go and
look at frogs even sure are real anymore
are we giving guns to chimps are we are
we building forts for them and teaching
them to use stone and I mean we've seen
now there's more videos coming out
showing like ember watch primate species
but using more tools yeah will this be
your undead stuff they believe that
primates chimps have entered the Stone
Age yeah they're using them on a regular
basis are we gonna go and teach them
their culture I mean do we do we teach
chimps things all the time what in each
imposed
yeah.but environments because that's the
only way you can study them yeah we
teach I mean if we they had a
civilization you can go to you knew they
lived in an apartment and you can study
them that way but you don't think that
they would study if they found a planet
like it looks the magic if we found a
planet okay we found a planet and it's
all just filled with octopus and these
octopus are changing colors and just
Jack and fish and eaten lobsters we
would be so it'd be fascinating
absolutely well all innovation happens
because people are trying to improve on
initial designs now why do they try to
prove and improve on initial designs
they try to make things that are better
make things that are more efficient make
things that can do tasks that they can't
do without these tools and then they
their curiosity and their creativity
causes them to expand upon these ideas
well of course if something's going to
be so far advanced they didn't accept
their current place in the universe
they don't even accept the fact they
want to stay on this planet they want to
travel to other places do you know
[ __ ] insanely curious you'd have to
be to lock you and three of your other
three-foot buddies and a giant [ __ ]
flying saucer and propel yourself
through space oh yeah we would have to
be incredibly curious and incredibly not
just curious but innovative they would
have to be thinking about things they
would have to be exploring things and of
course you would want to come to a
planet that is filled with people who
have hundreds of different languages
they're all full of [ __ ]
they lie to each other constantly send
videos through the air they have weapons
that they could blow each other up with
yeah I mean of course you would be
fascinated by that is the least
compelling argument
that anybody ever says why would they
mess with us why would they care about
us of course they would care about us we
are [ __ ] interesting well I'll put
this way I think if we saw like a group
of chimps standing near like a water
water bed and then one chimp fashioned
some kind of bag and pulls it over its
head jumps in the water and tries to go
as low as he can for as long as I can
but before coming back out we would look
at that like that is the stupidest
attempt at scuba diving I've ever seen
but oh my god a chimp just tried to
scuba dive so if there are aliens and
they're in these amazing technologically
advanced ships that can jump Lightspeed
manipulate gravity they just watched us
strap ourselves to an explosive and fire
us off of our atmosphere where we're
likely to die and they're like this is
the in stupidest attempt that actually
go into space he's guys trying to go to
space no I wouldn't think about that way
at all I would think about look there's
a [ __ ] Space Station it's up there
and people live on it they shoot
themselves is that they have a very
crude form of propulsion right but they
have figured it out because they don't
have element 115 in their environment
naturally so these dummies have to light
things on fire and usually push off the
back of it to shove themselves through
normal air and you know why they're not
gonna give us that Tech right now why
would they give us that why why do I say
give us tax why they wouldn't I'm saying
why would they give us tech why would
any that's the weirdest argument ever
that they're giving us things I don't
think they're giving a [ __ ] no I don't
think so either I think they're
specifically not doing it and they
wouldn't do it even if we wanted them to
I think I think it's the inverse you you
people a lot of people talk about how
they're like sharing technology with us
or something right you see that stuff in
the conspirators conspiracies
the reason they won't is because we're
we're trust we're territorial we we
fight each other I'm sure so look if
they came down and went to Russia and
said here's anti-graft propulsion we
think Russia is gonna do all right our
planet now they're gonna immediately
expand rapidly their population is gonna
grow exponentially and it's gonna cause
massive turmoil between nuclear powers
which could destroy themselves
so you can use it as a weapon the
smartest thing is to not share at all
until we're a one-world you know Society
well also like look at what they look
like when aliens look like if you look
at the iconic shape of an alien they
have giant heads and genderless bodies
like maybe that's the key to to stopping
war with the north
no incentive whatsoever for people to be
sexual or attractive everybody looks
exactly the same we get over this idea
of biological mating they reproduce
through genetic engineering why not just
be robots well maybe they are like yeah
that's me that is like a robot
artificial bodies where you you know
have you seen altered carbon I haven't
but I keep hearing good things about it
I just finished season 2 season 1 was
awesome but basically they have a thing
called a stack you said you finished
season 2 season 1 is awesome that means
season 2 sucks
season 2 is a C+ Oh season 1 second a
plus plus yeah like it's fun but they
have a thing called a stack in the base
of their in their in their spinal column
right below their their head that stores
their consciousness and they call their
bodies sleeves and they kind of don't
care when they die because they just get
you know it's if you're poor you get
really crappy sleeves right but if
you're if you're rich you get premium
access military upgrade like high tech
very strong but their body has just
become separate and you can also
transport your consciousness
interstellar like to other planets and
then you wake up in a body in a
different plant that's how you go places
now your consciousness travels so yeah I
mean maybe aliens do that maybe there's
there's not you know I'm I find the the
idea of the various alien life but the
body's curious one of the one of the
things I've read about is that it could
be humans from the future yeah I've
heard that - that makes sense you think
about what we look like as opposed to
like what a champ looks like yeah and
then you keep going further with that
like oh the head will get bigger the
bodies get weaker yeah and then look
there's a sort of a trend in this
society today to be less masculine less
feminine more gender-neutral and these
well so they them pronouns maybe that's
all just part of the programming this
this falls into another one of these
conspiracy theories that the goal of the
globalists is that in order to get
access to alien tech we have to be a
unified planet aliens aren't going to
give aliens really you've heard that one
oh yeah it's all over the Internet the
that's why they're doing this so that
they're going with a one-world order in
order to get alien tech do you think the
Galactic Federation is gonna gonna let a
planet in which has got numerous
governing bodies and nuclear weapons
there's a Galactic Federation think I'm
just
right about the point I'm making is
they're people and I believe this they
believe that if there is some kind of
Galactic Federation or at least some
kind of recognizable you know different
cultures that have some kind of set rule
base right who do they negotiate with us
Russia or China and so the argument the
one of the theories is that interest on
the United States who have access to the
aliens know that they have to do
everything their power to unify the
entire planet under one Authority so
that we can be entered into whatever
alien you know access would exist but so
long as we are nuclear-powered competing
territorial factions they can't do it
well that makes sense if that was the
case but you add in what you what you
were saying about masculinity and gender
and one of the things that I find
interesting is that when it comes to
this argument about removing masculinity
there's this kind of overlap with this
idea of domestication you think about
proto twelves proto dogs and dogs dogs
are effectively wolf cubs perpetually so
wolves are aggressive territorial
independent yeah I mean independent the
sense that like you you're not gonna
tame them they're like you know teach
wolves yeah yeah willing to listen to
you there I mean I you you can but it's
like it's it's Sarah they agree with you
or they don't you're following you know
so an adult masculine tough human is
gonna be like I'm independent I'm in
charge they've got to remove that and
domesticate us so you get a bunch of
weak effeminate genderless humans who
are gonna be passive docile and
agreeable
yeah like dogs right yeah do I have a
whole bit about what wolves are and what
dogs are yeah and what men used to be
right and what men are now yeah I I was
thinking of this really cool idea for a
sci-fi film where aliens come to earth
and most humanity accepts domestication
and then 300 400 years from now you've
got regular looking 21st century kind of
men and women but then you have these
five-foot tall super armored jet pack
with plasma rifles that love and serve
the aliens and we view them as freakish
genetic defects so have you seen like
oblivion with Tom Cruise yes
the aliens basically genetically
engineered a whole bunch of Tom Cruise's
I was thinking of that kind of idea but
also with domestic Asia that's an
underrated movie by the way that's cool
I love it
yeah very good
if if aliens came to earth and most
humans agreed and then over time the
humans that got access to life-saving
technology special armor were the ones
that were agreeable and less likely to
be aggressive yeah they would [ __ ] out
just like the Wolves bitched out and
became a pole and then you'd have wolves
so I thought of a cool idea for a story
you basically if humans like raiding a
chicken coop and the aliens are like ah
and they call their attack humans who
jump out with like armor and crazy
feature tech from the aliens but they're
like these small dong the like versions
of humans you know like desperately in
love with the aliens you know right
justice crying in logs yeah yeah wolves
aren't like that but I wonder if the
people would eat those doglike people
the way wolves eat dogs well for the
sake of a fiction no we wouldn't have
them do that but what would kind of
always be coyote be like this sneaky
smaller but our carios aren't the
product of domestication I mean they're
just a separate Kain canine breed I
guess or species right but I'm saying
like they they really never got
domesticated yeah that's what's
interesting it's like they're I mean you
zero coyote version of humans yeah the
North Sentinel island right you know
yeah yeah the people who've never had
contact with humans well they had
several bad people well that's why they
killed that guy they killed that I
shouldn't hear he killed the missionary
because they were invaded in the 1800s
by a guy named Maurice of Adal Portman
who was a pervert / Explorer who you
know would measure dicks and yeah take
detailed descriptions of people's
anatomy and genitals I mean was it for
legitimate research purposes no [ __ ]
wacko just yeah fine people and run
tests on them yeah but that would be
what we'd worried about with aliens too
right that's why that's why people were
worried about them touching their
[ __ ] well somebody's only the pervert
aliens somebody posted this tweet they
said something about like you need to
realize the aliens who would come to
earth aren't the cool nerds who want to
like talk science it's they're the rich
[ __ ] who you know rat [ __ ] their
planet and they're dipping out the myth
that's a silly way to look at it well I
mean it's one possibility
I understand but that's us
we always want to look at things through
like a human centric filter exactly but
if they're genderless things from from
the future like what benefit would it be
to get richer
you know these they have their giant
heads and they could travel the speed of
light like this is this is why I really
don't like I think it's Hawking's
argument that we shouldn't we shouldn't
be excited about aliens because whenever
a more powerful civilization approaches
a weaker one they dominate it's like I
don't buy no buy that for two seconds in
terms of aliens coming earth that makes
no sense what what so the argument I buy
what Hawking's argument oh you don't
that if aliens came to earth they would
enslave us to steal our resources well I
don't necessarily think they would
enslave us to steal our resources but if
we were aware of them they would become
space daddy well what he's what he's
saying is like you know when when the
Europeans came to North America and
spread disease and then stole land start
wiping everybody out like when a more
advanced civilization meets oh you know
you know I don't think aliens would do
that at all it's like why not the way I
the way I would view the most
devastating approach would be more like
a gigantic vessel coming down and just
slicing a skyscraper in half and
stripping out all the copper and
elements while ignoring the people and
when we go to a habitat for animals
we're not going to like haha we'll kill
all the squirrels we're like we're
taking the lumber squirrels be damned
so we go into habitats where other
creatures live take what we want and we
don't care about the animals we don't we
farm we kill all the mice and our little
critters in there we don't care so I
don't like the I don't think the
argument makes sense that a more
advanced civilization would come to
earth and be like haha humans now you
will serve us and it's our land now they
would have completely ignore us and just
start taking stuff and crushing us and
ignoring us it wouldn't be but I don't I
don't think that's the the most likely
scenario either I think any any race
sufficiently advanced enough to travel
the massive size of the universe would
have little need for the primitive
elements on our planet and it actually
be substantially easier for them to go
to any other empty Rock no it's not true
we have no idea no we have no idea what
they need like what this might be an
incredibly rare place incredibly rare as
far as everything we've been able to
observe they might come here because
they found this Goldilocks planet that
has liquid water and incredible
biodiversity and more like
than any other place on earth already a
little place in the solar system you
know the or in the known galaxy you know
the eros planet theory right was that
that's a leap there's an elliptical
orbit for a planet that every 300 years
comes in comes in close orbit to earth
gets elliptical around our Sun yeah
that's planet Nibiru Nibiru yeah yeah
that they they used human slave labor
for mining gold yes that's all zecharia
sitchin yes it is I've heard the name
and stuff he wrote a book called the
12th planet that's a fascinating take on
the ancient Sumerian texts and he's
widely been criticized by other scholars
who understand ancient Sumerian yeah and
there's actually a website called
Sitchin is wrong see if you can go to it
Sitchin is wrong calm because all the
whack jobs like me who love the idea of
you know all that's why we're so into
gold man right because the aliens use
these suspended gold particles and their
atmosphere atmosphere to protect their
atmosphere from deterioration by their
you know in industrial use of chemicals
and toxins has destroyed their
environment so Sitchin is wrong calm is
an interesting website and I don't know
who's right or who's wrong and I think
if you want to go over the Anunnaki and
the ancient but what's really
interesting and not just about Sitchin
but about Sumer in general is one thing
is they had these tablets these clay
tablets that had a depiction of the
galaxy or the depiction of the solar
system
now you're talking about 6000 BC they
have this depiction of the solar system
that shows the Sun in the center and it
shows all of the planets in our known
galaxy are known solar system with a
proper perspective in terms of the size
of the planet and the proper distance
like they're in the right places
it's not like there's a big one really
close to the Sun then there's a little
one three planets out like see if you
can find that it's a weird image see
that's the image yeah right yeah yeah
they're the take that zecharia sitchin
had was that they were trying to tell us
that they have come from this other
planet and they were trying to explain
to us what our solar system is but just
the
they have this Sun in the center and
then they have all the planets that we
know of circling this Sun and this has
been criticized like oh no they didn't
do it riding it didn't do it first of
all they did it in clay okay
so relax there so it's so goddamn close
that you would have to say man that
might be what that is and if that is
what that is what are they trying to say
with this thing
because there's also an image from a
clay tablet of a very large being that
has a very small human-like being with a
monkey tail on its lap and this is what
Sitchin points to as some sort of a
depiction of the genetic engineering
that took place to turn primitive
primates into human beings this is the
reason why we are so different from
every other animal on this planet and
the real thing that when when people
talk about aliens and alien Kali what
would aliens be doing here why would
they do what if human beings are the
product of accelerated evolution like
what if they came down here they found
this incredibly rich planet that's
filled with biodiversity and all these
different life forms and then they found
these primates and like oh we know where
these [ __ ] are going like this is us
ten billion years ago or whatever the
[ __ ] it is let's accelerate this little
party let's inject some of our super
advanced DNA into these primates and
let's see let's see where it takes
itself so what do you think you think
yeah that's a fun story right that's the
story that they told Bob Lazar but Bob
Lazar said I don't know if they told me
that to throw us off the trail if it's
disinformation or if it's just some
wacky thing that they came up with to
just like have a crazy story that the
scientists couldn't tell anybody so if
you do tell people like what are you
working on I'm working on a reverse
engineering a propulsion system from an
aircraft that came from another planet
and by the way right we are a product
product of accelerated evolution they
came to us and they injected our DNA and
you know we'll think about that star in
the context of ancient religions and a
lot of the commonalities notably like
Abrahamic this idea that we were created
that we were told we
shouldn't do certain things so I think
these are all fun stories but yeah you
could look at the idea of someone being
the Son of God you know a hybrid right
yeah you could look at the stories of
regular ol Genesis taking the rib of
Adam to creative well yeah the genetic
matter sure and then manipulating it so
you know I get I get a lot of heat from
my more religious friends for pointing
that out that I believe the Bible is
more likely at an odds base to be about
aliens and about the actual creator of
the universe and I'm talking
astronomical odds like ridiculously
astronomical but I think we actually
know some things exist genetic
manipulation cargo cults we know how
primitive life-form reacts to more
advanced technologies they don't
understand and that would would would
make more sense to me than you know
believing in a hard religion about the
Creator and you know carpenter's son
things like that yeah well it's also
we're dealing with translations Yeah
right that have gone on for thousands
and thousands of years that are a story
that was told as an oral tradition for a
thousand years before that like boy the
saying hard-and-fast exactly what they
meant in the Bible and what this means
and what must have happened for them to
write that down to me is just bonkers I
mean yeah who who knows but what we do
know is that the older the stories get
the weirder they get like that's one of
the weird things about the ancient
Sumerian texts is that you're dealing
now you're in like the 6,000 years ago
range yeah which is really weird
like that's a long [ __ ] time like oh
I saw that conversation had that dude
about the Sphinx I think he's I was like
9,000 BC or something well this is a
Graham Hancock and or Robert Schoch
Robert Schoch who's a geologist at
Boston University is actually taken the
time to examine the erosion around the
outside of the Sphinx see the Sphinx
itself has been worked on a lot there's
been a lot of rehabilitation of the
pause they've sort of rebuilt it which
is kind of a shame but it's it's made
out of a sort of a soft stone you know
it's eroding and falling apart and when
they found the Sphinx like when
and found the Sphinx it was buried it
was buried under sand so this is the
thing that had been buried and reexpose
many times they think throughout history
and what Robert Schoch had found in
discovering this the temple where the
Sphinx was carved and the the area that
surrounds us Fink's was this deep
fissures in the walls that were
indicative of thousands of years of
rainfall the problem with that is the
last time there was rainfall in the Nile
Valley was 9,000 BC right right right so
they're dealing with like in and you
have to go back thousands of or 9,000
years ago might be 7000 BC but you have
to deal with thousands of years of
rainfall prior to that to create this so
that means that this was something that
was clearly carved by a man has
thousands of years of rainfall that
eroded it and you're dealing with a time
period where the last time they had this
rainfall in this area was thousands of
years before they think people were even
capable of building things like this
maybe it was a lizard people you know
that theory about the super intelligent
dinosaurs that flood underground no
there's so many wacky theories it's
funny right what I'll roll my eyes at
isn't it even slightly even tiny tiny
bit more likely that humans came from a
different planet and after they
destroyed it and then receded and we
lost our way of life yeah it's possible
look if we're gonna go to Mars like what
is the [ __ ] origin tale gonna look
like a hundred thousand years from now
once we go to Mars let's take the the
the climate change you know global
warming stuff to its logical conclusion
of rising tides and a greenhouse runaway
greenhouse effect right so we we built
one ship Elon Musk builds one ship with
a very small crew of you know how many
people are gonna be on that you know on
his gotta have some chicks though yeah I
think I already populate the earth right
so it's got to be men and women and the
people are gonna have to be boys
heterosexuality is gonna be favored yeah
because you really can't have gay people
that aren't going to breed on a you know
you have two lesbians like oh we need to
have it only populated by lesbians well
there's no more yes do you guys have
buckets a sperm and a turkey baster cuz
how else you gonna make people when
you're over there
I was reading that they're gonna go with
people who are already coupled and
they're gonna you know with like ten
couples or whatever I don't know about
you and most specifically but that was a
lot of swapping normal space they did
talk about there too I was reading like
the the most optimal theory for
colonizing Mars would be like amorous
people something like ten people already
coupled now that they're polyamorous but
they expect there's gonna be commingling
eventually expect commingling oh so it's
Burning Man in space but but but check
it out let's say let's say we sent a
Mars expedition you know ten families
we've got you know two of each start
having kids they send cargo there they
start building and then earth wipe
itself up runaway greenhouse we can't
get it control things nuclear war
whatever right the planet becomes a
desolate wasteland there's no more
communication to those who are on Mars
so the last remaining you know hundred
or so people who are now on Mars the
adults who remember earth write down a
book here's everything happened here we
shouldn't shouldn't do here's how he
lived and they give to their kids now
their kids never experienced earth and
know nothing about it
in fact those kids only have a fleeting
image of the technology that they once
had now go two more generations down the
old tack where we used to colonize Mars
is now decaying and falling apart they
have no idea to fix it the original
colonists are dead go down three more
generations and I've got a few thousand
humans start moving off looking for
resources and no one has any idea earth
even was a real thing other than stories
they heard about the military leader in
the in the in the orbital orbital Space
Station who long since died so now they
have this book they don't fully
understand their language is now
changing as they separate from each
other and find different heirs of the
planet now English or whatever language
they were speaking becomes ten different
languages now they're translating the
book now it's a thousand years later
they're not even on earth existed and
they have this weird book about the way
things used to be and now the billions
of you know now we're ten thousand
twenty thousand years in the future and
they find you know these old ancient
relics and they're like I wonder what if
you don't even smoke pot dude no man I
don't smoke imagine if you did oh my
gosh you know did you'd have so many
more of these theories one that's a good
theory but I that's to me that's the
logical conclusion that's why I like the
story of like humans came from Venus
not saying it's true there's a there's a
oh there's a group of people from
Africa that actually the the Dogon did
Oh John people's that what is Dogon
people and they they talked about the
very specific area of Mars where human
beings came from and they have a really
weird understanding of cosmology like
they they know some things that like hmm
where'd you what and their their origin
story is that people were living on Mars
and that they destroyed Mars and how to
escape Mars and come to earth and so
it's sort of a very similar version of
it and now when you add that to what
they know about Mars that Mars used to
be like a hospitable place to tell any
water yeah nothing about this way to
let's say that we had an orbital space
station over the new planet we're
terraforming mmm
what kind of government would exist
let's say earth is wiped out right the
only survivors on an orbital space
station over Mars with a small colony in
the base it's gonna be a military
dictatorship not intentionally not from
this evil perspective but from a your
the general your second-in-command we've
always operated this way it's a military
mission you know the person who's in
charge is in charge and then eventually
you build up the colony to a certain
point where second and second in command
or one of the favorite lieutenant says
it's time to enact democracy and the
general says [ __ ] no and then a civil
war breaks out in the heavens people on
the ground watching the ships shoot at
each other and blow each other up and
then all the technology gets wiped out
you should really start smoking pot no
no you know what you know but there's a
lot of ways to interpret like various
ancient spiritual religious texts in
science fictiony kind of way so I
actually you know talk to my friends
about this we like kind of what if what
if the Bible and and you know the Old
Testament were viewed from a science
fiction perspective not to be disrespect
I'm not trying to disrespect anyone's
religion anything like that but like
what if we tried to apply a lens of from
a futuristic perspective of our
understanding of Technology to how they
may have viewed what was going on back
then so you know what the cargo cults
are yes for those that don't it's you
know these natives on these islands saw
planes didn't know if they were so they
built effigies of the planes like I
guess hoping they'd come back or
whatever right so
I saw that I wondered you know a lot of
people ask that question what if we did
the same thing with aliens and the other
question is what would we do if we
destroyed our own planet like people say
we are and how would that how would that
you know result in a government how that
resulting stories it would be so fun if
we destroy this planet we go to Mars and
repopulate Mars and fix it up and then
destroy that place and come up at Earth
after we're done cuz I look at what's
going on right now during this pandemic
the skies are clear than ever before the
Venice canals in Italy of dolphins in
them now you can see the ground
jellyfish you realize how disgusting we
are and yeah we're gross like what we've
done the Los Angeles is amazing and in
just a month and a half the air is
pristine crystal-clear you can see
forever it's a different world now
imagine if that's what happens if we go
to Mars we [ __ ] that place up come
back to earth look it's fixed we're back
you know I guess if we can sustain our
technology yeah did you find one Dogon
tribe find that it actually says talking
about see Siri right but didn't they
have something about Mars as well I
typed literally that and Mars and that
just took me to serious stuff instead of
Mars serious yeah the star Sirius but
they understand they have a story or if
you can it's a it's a weird thing in
terms of like the cosmology like what
they understand and this is you know
relatively primitive tribe that has this
origin story well it's like the end of
they find earth the [ __ ] new
Battlestar Galactica is so good isn't it
yeah it's one of the reason trade yeah
then the more recent one one of the most
underrated science fiction series ever
it was so good well not not to act like
my ideas are original the series ends
with them discovering the habitable
planet yes with what did it
spoiler alert spoiler alert with a
species that's compatible with them
yeah they find primitive humans yes and
so if that story you know it's an
interesting story yes we would lose all
knowledge of the previous planets and
technology and well imagine if we flew
to another planet for the first time we
landed there and it's like 1940s America
like whoa or maybe do if we could [ __ ]
them
you know they'd be so impressed with you
well what if what if we find a spaceship
underground with ancient Tech and we
don't know what it is in turn that's
ours the Dogon tribe the Nomo and
they're fascinating cosmic knowledge
deep in northwest Africa more precisely
in Mali we find one of the oldest most
fascinating ancient cultures to develop
on earth so the ancient Dogon tribe is
known for the religious traditions
ritual dances their massive ritual masks
their wooden sculptures in their
architecture however they're also known
for their incredible astronomical
knowledge and their fascinating
mythological accounts
the Dogon have a compelling ancient
tradition they mentioned myths and
legends that go thousands of years into
the past
predating possibly even their own
history some authors like Robert Schoch
who's also the guy from Boston
University he's the geologist that
talked about the Sphinx argue that the
Dogon were people who originated in
Africa but who had been forced to leave
ancient Egypt due to their religious
persecutions it is in his opinion that
the Dogon may preserve ancient Egyptian
traditions and myths that may even have
been carried into the present age
claiming that the Dogon have a powerful
cosmic connection I can go on for this
will take too long to read yeah cuz I'm
just gonna just whelmed so what is that
coincidence ancient knowledge well it's
just they understand the the cosmos and
you could you'd have to go and hear the
story but it's a it's a weird story it's
a weird like oh how do they know this
like what what a weird origin story but
you've seen zeitgeist yeah yes where
where you know the first time he talks
about the three kings of Orion's belt
pointing to the star in the east where
the Sun rises in the third day yeah yeah
maybe maybe their stories are just just
that you know we look what could we do
but stare at the sky and that's a good
point yeah when you stop and look if you
were traveling across the country as you
were did you get a chance to stop and
look in the middle of nowhere at this at
the sky of course [ __ ] amazing
yeah there's Nick Ulis there's a grouse
that were robbed of that yeah and it
wasn't it there's a story that I think
in Los Angeles the power went out
there's blackout in the 90s and the
police got tons of calls from people who
didn't know what they were seeing in the
sky
it was the Milky Way galaxy those are
the same people that are injecting lice
all right now
they aren't though you know well
somebody might it's probably a few yeah
well you know if you're gonna what about
how chloroquine thing you know when the
one form of chloroquine that was but the
the form that was a pond cleaner
oh yes husband but here's the thing the
lady wasn't she like a democratic
contributor and donor she treated that
Donald Trump was a psycho like that and
and her and her husband took the stuff
well there's new reporting that says the
husband was an engineer his friends are
shocked that he would do something so
stupid
so the wife poison him that's the theory
that's going around now now the the
FairPoint brought up I think it was a
free beacon is that he trusted his wife
and he loved her Wow poor she's really
dumb but I'm [ __ ] out of apparently a
couple decades ago she had struck him
there's a report about it
Oh decades ago yeah twenty years I think
but there's also reports and you gotta
factor this stuff for sure because it's
not like something I've been diving too
much too deep into but she was trying
divorce the guy so the story popping up
is that donor Carol Baskin of
chloroquine that's what people have been
saying yeah like the rumors going around
but whether or not any that's true it's
like you know I always say give me the
proof but I can't tell you this the
media loves to run everything the
president says through a filter of like
it must be taken literally or to its
worst most the opposite have benefited
out the the most negative conclusion
possible if he says it we're gonna run
the most negative interpretation it's
bad it's awful you know so when he says
something like you know that Peter
Navarro instance where he said you know
you're nasty reporter he said about
hydroxychloroquine and chloroquine it
might work it might not but I'm
optimistic what are the press run with
Trump recommends untested dangerous drug
meanwhile you get a scrupulous Proust no
no press room with that right right of
course but but look when Andrew Cuomo
came out and said we're gonna start
trialing you know chloroquine
hydroxychloroquine and is it her Meissen
where was the negative press didn't they
say that that has actually been proven
to kill more people than not using it
though the one six yeah one of the
initial stories to come out said that it
actually more likely to kill so the CDC
had listed that this was actual
treatment used by many countries and we
have there's a lawmaker in Michigan
she's a Democrat she was given the
treatment she had saved her life and she
personally praised the president for it
for that she's being censured and being
stripped of any I've heard of that it
sounds crazy it is it is there's a
reason why they were using it these
shouts it showed some promise with some
people I guess the idea was that the the
extreme immune system reaction in your
lungs was killing people mm-hmm the
swelling and the fluid buildup so by
suppressing the immune system you would
stop that from happening
these symptoms would abide and you'd
eventually recover you know what man if
the media that there's a graph showing
the amount of press Obama got versus
Trump what Trump got and I think to a
certain degree Trump thoughts on himself
because he chased after this press and
he baits them and he goes after them
right but it's like three or four times
as much news but it's also a different
world now if you go back to 2000 Oh 8
2008 rather when Obama was elected the
influence of like online media and the
ability to pull eyes away from
traditional media sources was nothing
was nothing people newspapers were still
real people are buying newspapers yeah I
mean the mainstream media was the only
way you got your news now there's people
like you you know there's there's
there's people like kolinsky or jimmy
dore there's there's people like the
hill they have these online platforms
where this is they're not only they more
viable than the traditional media
outlets they're more accurate they're
they're less biased they're they're
younger or more intelligent and they're
not connected to some gigantic media
machine that has a very consistent bias
I think we're seeing substantially more
bias than ever before and seeing from
online things wrote from from from into
everything from everything but it starts
with it people like me so look I'm an
individual I have an opinion there are
things that I think are more important
to other things I look at this
establishment press this behemoth
constantly lying to people not every
single journalist I know many
journalists they're fantastic their jobs
they risk their lives they do good
stories even political reporters you
know my respect to Ben Smith formerly of
BuzzFeed news now
time's calling out the New York Times
well sort of for their defense of Joe
Biden calling out CNN great reporters
but you have a lot of people in media
who's their goal is just survive make
money and so what happens with YouTube
one of the reasons I think they started
censoring a lot of channels is what
works shock content sensational rage
bait mm-hmm so YouTube's hard suppresses
that it's not entirely fair but there's
no real good answer to how you deal with
this and it's unfair to a lot of
independent creators because like you
mentioned YouTube doesn't know better
they're like who's credible but CNN
starts adopting the same tactic so now
you know CNN realize and they can't win
no matter what they do they're competing
with with free videos on Facebook you
know you know mom-and-pop who post that
video from the rally on Facebook cost
them nothing they don't care and CNN's
got to pay someone 30 to 50 thousand
dollars a year at a low level to make
this kind of content they're losing so
they switched it up now we're being told
that there are counter built you know
are a credible you're credible news
outlets authoritative sources they're
the same thing as what the youtubers
were look I mean when you get Don Lemon
going on on the show asking if a black
hole swallowed an airplane how's that
any different from the crackpots on it
was Don Lemon asked a guest if a black
hole swallowed the missing Malaysian
airplane wait a minute he was serious he
said I know it's preposterous but is it
preposterous and the woman responded
never to see the totally yeah Don Lemon
Don Lemon asked about black hole swung
airplane I get a kick out of him okay I
like when he gets mad but it's
performative it's not real news so you
know I think it's great that I think
we're seeing a certain kind of creator
emerge that are good I think Jimmy and
Kyle are awesome I think I do a good job
don't think I'm perfect but I think
we're all biased and so that's why I
always tell people you can't just watch
me like you definitely got to watch Kyle
Pakman or jimmy dore and i get a lot of
heat cuz people like you always
recommend these left-wing channels oh my
god right steven crowder you know for
instance sticks accent hammer these are
good good youtube channels but we're
biased I think we all try to be as
honest as we can these big corporate
channels are trying to survive they
don't care about honesty so brian
Stelter on CNN actually said he shows a
bunch of videos from fox news and says
don't watch the spin watch us we're
gonna give you the facts don't look man
if someone
you not to seek information outside I
wouldn't trust that I don't want to tell
you what to listen to
but I will tell you if you only watch my
stuff you're missing out you got to
watch other perspectives I want to see
Don Lemon and brian Stelter unmake Adana
frayed out in the woods you get trapped
by saying the black hole thing he did it
this is from 2014 oh yeah was that when
it was from I think so yeah a while ago
I'm hear him say that something fully
that we don't really understand a lot of
people have been asking about that about
black holes and on and on and on and all
of these conspiracy theories let's look
at this Noah says what else can you
think about black hole Bermuda Triangle
and then desi says huh just like the
movie lost and of course it's also
they're also referencing the twilight
zone which is a very similar plot that's
what people are saying I know it's
preposterous but is it preposterous you
think Mary well it is a black holes
about you know a small black hole would
suck in our entire universe so we know
it's not that muted triangle is often
weather and lost is TV show so I think
okay he's just being provocative to get
someone to answer a silly questions be
sure and heed about on the Internet he's
not saying it like he believes it no no
what I mean is that he's presenting the
conversation that's what's become it's
become well I think he's doing
entertainment because first of all back
then I mean this was 2014 September 20
feet I think people were just starting
to understand like the impact of
comments and and they were addressing
them and they were probably trying to
silence a lot of the nonsense but then
you get a woman stupid chilly a small
black hole with small small of the whole
universe yeah well I don't think she's a
real expert if she said that right so
why is Don Lemon asking nonstic
equestions to pay to guests who can't
answer them properly at all well he's
just trying to be provocative I get it I
get it and so what I mean to say is that
you're watching must've look at where
they were in 2014 look where they are
now with faking the Chris Cuomo thing
they've that's his idea the the Chris
Cuomo know pretty gross did you hear
what he said on his radio show know what
he said he said I don't find value in
what I do I think it's ridiculous he
said I don't like what I do for a living
I don't like an
I think you know and then he said
something defective I'll never beat them
in reference to like Hannity and Maddow
or some like that I think in my person
in ratings
yeah and rating so he's their biggest
show he is I'm pretty sure Cuomo is
their biggest show yeah this is the only
one that seems to be a man and he
doesn't crack a million in the ratings
really yeah it's like eight and I think
it's like 800 to 900 I think he
periodically might the ratings might be
going up I could be wrong so check the
latest ATS but I hear something Kevin I
think that the CEO producers went to him
and said look man you you got this thing
like we should we should we should run
with it let's like go to your house
we'll film it we'll make it this big
deal I think so and I think it wasn't
that bad I think he had mild symptoms
look the dude went out the guy left his
home he was you know when he was talking
about the the issues he was having he
was he seemed normal right like here's
what I don't expect from someone who is
as sick as he seemed to be I don't feel
that good but hey I'm one of the lucky
ones now he's normal
yeah that's what I would expect he's
saying he's shivering so hard he's
chipping his teeth seems ridiculous yeah
doesn't seem I don't know I mean maybe
when it's night time and you're tired
because one of the things I remember
last time I was sick was quite a while
ago at the end of the night I'd be like
really a key because I was tired and I
was as I was tired my immune system
would be depleted and then I would feel
the effects of the cold more and then
you wake up in the morning you feel a
lot better maybe pop some ibuprofen I
know he was taking tylenol so it's
supposed to take ibuprofen for this for
some reason well he said I think he was
taking time for Michael yo said that he
was told to take ibuprofen and when he
did it made it way worse no yeah well so
so here's what can I say I'm not gonna
accuse the guy a lot of people are for
any and everything got sick I don't
think that's the case he probably got
sick he tested positive but right I
think he it seemed fairly mild in
comparison to other people like Michael
yo when I talked to him what first of
all when he was doing a video talking
about recovering from it was coughing
yeah and in the video he was coughing
when he was talking about our Instagram
I'm thanking everybody but he had a bad
case of it where he got pneumonia and it
was rough and you know Michael's a
healthy guy so that was disturbing to me
but the Chris Cuomo version of
virus didn't seem that scary the dude
wasn't quarantined okay he went out to
some property 30 minutes from his home
presumably with his family he was
witnessed by somebody else not supposed
to do that right no you're not I mean
it's not just that but on CNN they said
he was locked down right they did this
whole reveal where he comes out of the
basements I've been waiting for this do
a tick-tock dance with his daughters I
don't know I think he did but I think
the reason he went on his show
complaining was because the movies
coming the producers told him to do this
fake thing and he didn't want to do it
he want you look man I worked when I
make sense he can't call them out cuz he
wants to keep the job when I worked for
you know one of these companies they
told me to side with the audience we
talked about it last time I was here
mm-hmm
they wanted me to create a narrative
that the audience agreed with because we
were there to serve them what was the
narrative young progressives whatever
they say
so social justice so whatever young
progressives say I'm gonna side with
that and I told him I asked are you
saying that if there is a factual news
story that would be upsetting to
audience we won't cover it he said I
think that's fair yeah what was it that
Oh a OC said recently that people
shouldn't go back to work
the didn't revolt like they should yeah
they should protest like not go back to
work that to me was one of the craziest
things I've ever heard a politician
saying like if anything we need to get
the goddamn economy back on track I
wonder if she's gonna lose in her
primary she's gone up against a woman
named Michelle Caruso Cabrera who is a
moderate who actually sounds very
reasonable and it and it kind of breaks
my heart a bit because I remember how
Democrats used to be I'm like you can
look at the thing she talks about and
she's a very reasonable like she's got
like a book
she was an anchor for some I think for
like CNBC or something and she comes off
like I don't know kind of like maybe you
were me just how what used to be left
before they went became radical
activists and for social justice why do
you think they went that way why do you
think every social I mean you think so
yeah so you know there's a couple
different theories I have on it
conservatives are less likely to be on
line in a lot of areas of the country
they have weaker internet all right but
they're so active online they dominate
for sure and that's one of the reasons
they're like you know they get wiped out
a lot but you look at room you'll be
talking about conservatives yeah yeah
conservatives getting banned a whole lot
because they're very active
they do a lot of memes but I think so
how are you saying that they're less
likely to have good internet rural rural
towns have really bad internet but are
you good enough to be able to post on
Twitter like what do you mean no yes it
has phones but with if you've got
dial-up in the middle of the country
you're not posting a video or a photo on
your phone you are watching dial-up yeah
that's true ones doing it through their
phones that's a good point all right
what I think is that you've got a lot of
older people that are conservative a lot
of younger people that are liberal and
there's there's issues there with how
people interact online mm-hmm so my
assumptions my opinions things I've read
older people more likely to just follow
and read younger people more likely to
engage most people not likely to engage
at all it's something I think like 2% of
a country action is actually acting
around Twitter yeah but you end up with
internal biases the social media
companies who is authoritative and who
isn't echo chambers so a really good
example is like BuzzFeed news wrote a
story that the wuhan bio lab leak theory
is a right wing you know popular right
wing theory Trump supporters are pushing
it and here's why it's wrong but CNN ran
multiple segments about this and so when
when you have digital media framing
things as always like you ever wonder
why they never say left-wing you know
like in the media they'll say
conservatives did X they never say
liberals did X because they view
themselves as those people right so you
end up with social media companies that
view that kind of content as
authoritative left-leaning you end up
with left-wing activists and acceptable
marketability there was a study done
where they tracked essentially like it's
a visualization of location for various
aspects of than the Internet
conservatives are in this bubble
liberals in this bubble marketing
digital marketing companies overlapped
with resistance Twitter anti-trump so
what ends up happening is big marketing
firms based in New York City based in
Los Angeles very urban areas much more
likely to be blue have a blue
perspective they run commercials based
on a left-wing perspective politicians
see it with the television is saying
they see what the websites are saying
and they say this is what America wants
it's not it's what the hyperactive 2% of
Twitter wants so they fall into that
trap where they believe all this stuff
the reason Ocasio cortez became got
elected she won I think she got 17,000
votes
district of 750,000 like that's not
winning a real election but I was an
exploit it was exploiting the system so
you end up with someone who has views
that don't represent the overwhelming
majority this country in a very
high-profile position influencing Nancy
Pelosi and what you know one of the
reasons they think they even went for
with impeachment was because Ocasio
Cortes gave a statement where she said
it was a bigger scandal that the
Democrats would not impeach Trump next
thing we know Nancy Pelosi hops on board
with the idea and that blew up in their
face Trump ends up seeing his approval
rating go up he raises a ton of money it
would be really interesting if what did
him in was the Lysol [ __ ] oh that was
bad for him though yeah but I don't
think yeah I don't think it'll be it
what do you think is gonna happen in
November as of right now there's the
panic factor could be good for Trump the
fact that we're in a crisis
may mean people are desperate for
security and they don't want to take a
chance they don't take any chances and
Trump is a bully like I don't mean it
necessarily as like you know to the
Trump supporters get mad what I mean is
like he's he pushes people around and a
lot of people like that about him
that he yells the press what a lot of
people on the Left don't get is when he
yelled at that CNN guy you're a nasty
reporter his base was clapping standing
up saying thank you for finally calling
these people out right it was a good
thing you take that attitude next to
Biden do you think Biden's gonna make
anybody feel safe nah man I don't think
so so the argument I've put forward is
look man I'm a moderate person my
politics have always been left-leaning
pro-choice progressive tax government
programs all this good stuff grew up in
a city but I'm not super far left I need
an argument from you Donald Trump has
come forward with the economy was
booming lost unemployment in 50 years
best numbers of our lives up until the
pandemic he instituted a travel ban that
they dumped the Democrats are even
agreeing with at this point if you want
to convince me to vote for you and many
people like me I think you got to give
me an argument as to why Biden is better
but they're not they're saying stay
alive Joe Biden we just don't like Trump
but they really they really are they're
really doing it it's a good point and I
think if the economy does manage to show
some signs of resurgence around November
in in you know towards October in
September if he has some sort of a real
rock-solid plan and he can show you
where it's going this is what we're
planning on doing this we're going
have this by that and that by this by
the way Joe Biden is not gonna get
better his cognitive decline is going to
increase and it kidding it could drop
right off of a [ __ ] cliff you might
come around to where November is where
the gaffes are constant and they pull
him off of the public eye and they never
show him if the Democrats want to win
they'll run Michelle Obama we might have
a [ __ ] CGI Joe Biden with I'm not
kidding where he does it from some sort
of a remote location and they CGI the
[ __ ] out of his his face well I'll tell
you one thing that there's there's some
net positive Trump could look at in
terms of the pandemic worried
you know people trust him his approval
rating was going up when they were
televising his his press briefings as
soon as they stopped doing that as proof
writing start going back down so when
people hear what he was saying they
liked it but the other big factor is if
this persists beyond the election Joe
Biden will never debate him and we see
this in the press right now everyone
keeps saying it the more the longer Joe
Biden is hidden the batter his campaign
is doing because people can't see him
struggling the speaker just going
against Trump mail and voting I agree
with you about Michelle Obama but I
don't think she really wants to run well
I didn't I'm not sure she would either
but I'm saying that's there I think they
would win if they ran her they probably
would mail and voting I think will be
the downfall Republicans if if Mahlon
voting does get pushed through Nancy
Pelosi I believe she said she wants to
have mail-in voting confirmed the next
stimulus package if the lockdown
persists beyond November November and
mail-in voting is the go-to way the the
challenge you see a bunch of Republicans
saying that mail-in voting could lead to
fraud and it can write if somebody's mom
is like you know old and just like not
paying attention and you fill out for
her but the bigger issue I see for
Republicans is that uninitiated and
uninterested people will be voted for
and that means in big urban areas you'll
have a mom and a dad telling their kids
who normally don't care to vote just
fill it out just fill it out just vote
for the guy and that could potentially
hurt I thumped the real concern is in
the counting that's the concern but in
terms of fraud right fraud is so the
Republicans main concern is fraud then
someone's gonna take their kids packin
just flat-out for them right but I don't
think not just that also in how it's
counted right tracking them the
algorithm mailbox in the post office so
a mess I agree with all that no I think
I think you don't need to go so far as
to assume some
is going to snatch up all the ballots
it's possible and replace them I think
that's a bit too much for me I just
think right now we know the youth vote
swings left and they don't care about
voting you put the ballot in their house
they don't they didn't turn out for
Bernie they did not turn out they turned
out in some areas but they didn't turn
out so you get this very active base
online ranting about what they want they
don't actually go out for it put the bat
in their pocket send it to their mailbox
and their mom says there it is fill it
out they're gonna do it and so that's
gonna make sure the people who normally
aren't bothered to go vote will go vote
Tim Poole we just did three hours know
it or not it's always fun thanks for
taking the trip thanks for driving over
here in your bug out van it's good fun
how long you stay this part of the
country probably leave right away okay
yeah good luck come to Shannon and maybe
people wave to you along the way yeah
you have photos of the van the outside
where people could see it on Instagram I
have one she probably heard that one do
we got one ever man someone's gonna come
in my van and kick it in I don't know
that's not what I'm saying there's gonna
tattoo your face on their ass or
something something weird people are
weird man I had a weird story I didn't
get to it good denials I had a I had a
crazy guy show up in my house ooh
pedophile 4:00 in the morning wanted me
to tell a story I had to call the cops
wanted you to tell him a story wanted me
to tell the world his story about being
a pedophile I saw him like that about
about how he was innocent it wasn't true
so she shows up miles at 4:00 a.m. tried
breaking in so I wake up at 4:00 a.m. -
son of a gun either I don't have a gun
and so I call the police
this is crazy police showed up they
catch the guy they first Kim they tell
him to go home cops come back tell me to
buy a gun basically oh jeez it's not
easy thing to do but get this that
morning I wake up it's like 9 a.m. and I
got woken up at like 4:00 a.m. by this I
think was like 3 something and so
normally I do a segment first thing in
the morning airs at 10:00 a.m. and so
after dealing with all that I was like I
am not prepared I'm just gonna tell
people what happened and say don't come
to my house in the middle of recording
my segment that comes back so I checked
my security camera and I see him there
and I'm filming while it's happening so
I call the police and I'm like he's back
and I recorded all of it and then the
cops came and he took off I guess yeah I
was gonna bring it up cuz we were
talking about you know the end of the
world the apocalypse guns so it's not
easy to go to New Jersey
the cops were like if we're me I'd open
the door with a shotgun and I was like
yeah if I could get one in Jersey but
you can you just have to wait 10 days
right no you got to write an essay I got
to write an essay on why I need it yeah
and then you have to be accepted and
then they have to approve the essay and
they said they said typically takes 30
days but sometimes it can take up to a
year it's not supposed to take up to a
year that's kind of illegal that's what
I was told at the department but they're
like a move to Arizona or you could just
buy a gun in a grocery stores for jigna
so are you gonna go oh I don't know man
I'm gonna leave I'm I'm gonna move out
of Jersey nah yeah for sure so I'm in
the Philly area because of this partly
yeah but also because I want to expand
my business you know I look I do opinion
commentary on news stories and now it's
time to start hiring more people for
four straight news in fact checking so
there's been I have a fact-checking
build-out that I've been working on how
we're gonna write other agencies we're
gonna do a hundred randomly sampled
articles and we're gonna run them
through the spj and Reuters ethics codes
we're going to look for violations of
the ethics codes we're gonna apply them
so if BuzzFeed news runs a hundred
stories and we find that 63 are have
some kind of violation of a code of
ethics we give them the score of you
know 37 out of a hundred mm-hmm and then
people can see how we rate these
agencies and you can look at all the
stories you can look at exactly why we
disagreed and we'll highlight where the
violation occurred that's a great idea
so I need a building so I can hire
people to do it beautiful well let me
know when that gets up and running we'll
let everybody know and appreciate you
man I really appreciate your perspective
I appreciate you a the way you look at
things and it was great to talk to you
as a man for sure thank you but